[Music]
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
yo what's going on people King rich is
back again with another podcast good
evening and hi and welcome to Auntie
Jenny's video channel to Jenny's podcast
it's your boy The Fresh Prince of
someone
but I've been coffee free for four
months okay I gotta say that how could
everyone have someone out there for them
when there's more women than men like
I'm not saying you have to be submissive
to every old waste man walking around
I'm just saying that it would be
femininity would be in your nature
breaking it is to find somebody you're
compatible with that you like not just
of your same generation and that likes
the same things that you do go in there
having fun get out okay okay then then
get out then get out faster Esther then
get out I'm not here to get canceled
today most men want a woman that has
some degree of femininity where they
feel like they're taking care of taking
care of I'm ladylike I'm submissive and
you'll be surprised because I will say
to say no and I'll say what I want to
say with my mind but my demeanor doesn't
change and I'm going to look down on him
because at the end of the day whoever
you're with is a reflection of you what
has happened to society that has made
the normal man a waste man I would feel
so bad asking a guy to buy like a three
thousand dollar bag
[Music]
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
[Applause]
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way in and make sure
you ring that notification Bell a couple
announcements before we start the show
the first thing guys all blessing what
super chats are we reading today
10 or more and if you send a 50 Super
Chat wherever we're at in the panel I
will ask your questions so if you have a
50 Super Chat I will read it right away
um also guys make sure you
um go subscribe to our three talents
Channel Amiri and T Jenny and King
riches they have three channels make
sure you go subscribe also guys we are
looking to potentially sign more Talent
this summer so if you have a YouTube
channel that you want to start feel free
to pitch it to me just pearly things one
um on Instagram DM it to me there also
guys we have four membership tears
blessing how many tiers to open the chat
tonight
uh two
well we're not here sorry how many likes
I said tears how many likes one thousand
likes okay a thousand likes and we will
open the chat tonight also blessing what
are we saving for what are these
donations going towards we need a key
card we need to kick out cam anytime we
kick out someone like you saw in the
intro we need a camera to make sure that
we capture it so um all super chats are
going towards that also guys um the
third tier you get to connect with me on
social media fourth tier you get a
one-on-one call with me once a month do
you want to know how to get a million
subscribers in a year I'll tell you make
sure you sign up for that also guys they
took away my five Tick Tock accounts
five yeah so uh make sure you go follow
my sixth just pearly things they also
took away my Instagram so go follow my
backup one just pearly things one also
um we're potentially gonna do a meet up
either this Sunday or next Sunday so if
you guys want to be invited to that and
you want to know where it's at in London
make sure you sign up for our Google
form we may even do something where we
have like a concert with people that
have been on the show it's something I'm
in talks we'll see but if you want
updates on that make sure you sign up
for our Google form also guys
um
actually I think that's oh we have an
animation Channel just pearly animation
so make sure you go subscribe to that
okay so welcome to the show guys um we
have a special panel tonight so to start
everyone say your name your age your
relationship status and a fun fact about
yourself starting here and then go
around
hello my name is Ashton I am 24 years
old I am single and my fun fact is I'm
going to change the world I'm going to
motivate everyone how so just I think
it's all about mindset like so many
people have dreams and goals and
Ambitions but they're so scared because
they see the end result and it's so far
away so you like teach mindset is that
something to do on like social media and
I'm going to start um a podcast okay
yeah cool yeah
um go ahead
I'm Courtney uh her mic is muted I think
no go ahead can you hear me yeah yeah
I'm Courtney I'm 20 years old I'm a tick
tocker and I am happily single may I add
um and fun fact about me I'm a tick
tocker
hey guys my name is Layla I'm 24 years
old and a fun fact about me is I was on
X on a beach
[Laughter]
um hi I'm cadell I'm 28
um and uh a fun fact
I found out the other day actually that
the um strongest the strongest muscle in
the body is your jaw
says yeah it's a bit mad it's a jaw yeah
apparently so no way yeah so that's my
fun fact
it's pretty cool go ahead uh on Burger
you might know from Twitter a lot of
viral in there a couple of times
20 years old
and and I've based on the side Jonathan
Jonathan
God my name is Giovanni wadipi I'm 30
years old
nothing exclusive right now and my fun
fact I would just say that oh now we're
just giving through pain and
understanding
and it's you versus you and once you
realize that
and you win that battle with yourself
you have enough fortitude
no no battle
nothing fails in comparison so yeah okay
um thanks for coming guys welcome to the
show
um so today's topic we are talking about
virginity
[Music]
um it seems like that's you know
disappeared nowadays um when it comes to
women however we are going to get these
young ladies
um opinions on it so to start guys
I actually want to start with what do
you think the average body count is for
let's say a 22 year old
in today's day and age
um maybe like
between 10 and 20
wow 10 and 20. I think so yeah wow okay
uh what do you think I'm sorry about
seven seven
um I reckon ten is twenty yeah 10 to 20
yeah for a 22 year old
well ten it depends on relationships as
well because if you've been in a
long-term relationship then it's going
to be lower than someone else who's
always been single I'm just do you guys
know your friends body counts do they
tell you I feel like you have but I
actually can't remember I don't think
it's a big thing that matters I feel
like I'm just curious yeah like do you
know like you're at your close friends
like do they tell you how many people
they've slept with or I don't think body
count matters uh
do I don't even know what yours is do I
yeah
I think when you're when you're younger
it's something that you probably talk
about more but as you get older how old
are you 20 like that's 20. yeah 24
you're still young oh I feel old though
um but so in general people don't know
not really no no I don't think it's a
thing that people really talk about
nowadays this is a personal thing isn't
it so how did you guys guess the average
is that like based off of you guys's
yeah okay
okay you said body count doesn't matter
why
I just feel like if you wanna if you
wanna [__] [__] but
personally I feel like being in a
relationship and losing your virginity
is so much more better because
why is it better if it doesn't matter if
body count wouldn't it just be the same
because body count doesn't matter I
think the first time you want it to be
special because it's the unknown and
it's such like a big thing isn't it like
you haven't had sex before but I think
once you've had it you realize not that
it doesn't mean anything I don't mean
anything like that but
it's common everyone does it do you know
what I mean losing you guys's virginity
special or no I was drunk
[Laughter]
special was it special first time oh
you know are you a virgin
I mean I totally I'm at this point but
um because it's been so long you're like
a really born again virgin yeah
but not not a real version no not a real
virgin okay but why don't you think it
matters
I just don't feel like it matters like
everyone has different sexual desires
everyone you know everyone's more sexual
than other people
um and if you wanna if you're horny yeah
go and do it I think it doesn't matter
to men but it matters to women yeah yeah
really yeah what do you mean I don't
think men's body count matters men's
doesn't but women's does yeah so if if a
man came up to you he's like yeah I've
slept with like 247 girls you wouldn't
feel you wouldn't feel anything at all
you'll just be like it's calm as if you
stepped it fine all right this is how I
would think about it 240 if he told me
that I'd be like well I'm probably not
special enough to make this man slow
down so I'd probably pass but it does it
does affect you and it does affect you
let me finish but it's not the same
because I'm not repulsed by it I'm not
disgusted by it like I don't really care
like I don't really care what a guy's
past is but I just think of like on a
balance of probabilities if a dude slept
with 200 [__] well I'm gonna be the
special one that makes him
yeah and you know that's great I just
think like the odds aren't in my favor
yeah like 200 and me you know no it's
not that it's not that it's not that
yeah let's say you fought like 240
sketched hoes in this past you come
along you're a good girl you know what
I'm saying you're telling me 200 you
make his life like you make his baby oh
he comes home to you yeah I'm waiting
for po at home he's not gonna care he's
gonna want you okay there's it's just
experience you know that's true no you
know you know miracles happen but you
know no I would just think like out of
200 girls there had to be some good
girls in there and he's probably just
doesn't want to settle down that's how I
would look at it but it's not like it's
not like men because men are repulsed by
it like do you want a girl that slept
with 200 dudes I mean like you know I
agree with I agree with you I feel like
it actually doesn't matter when they're
with you it's like whatever happens in
the future like but at least at the same
time wifey injured by if my wife told me
was like these two guys hit first and
now she's on your arm I would be that I
thought that
doesn't mean it's
but it's just I think the society we
live in you know it's not it's not it's
not good to have a big number I presume
so I think that's sad though that it's
like that Society yeah yeah why should
numbers matter why did you care about
what people think all the time and that
evolves around everything I think your
past Behavior dictates your future
Behavior so it's like if you're sleeping
around for 10 years what are the chances
that you stop and it's the same thing
with like the guy that slept with 200 I
would think well what are the odds he
stops true but but isn't that like you
know I could help you know
um okay what what do you think the
average body count is for a 22 year old
uh
uh now yeah now I would say at least
about
15 to 17. I'll go 15 to 17. I'll say if
you're about 22 probably steps of about
just under 20 people
maybe unless you haven't been in a
relationship that's like three four
years
um and you've been single and you've
just been kind of dating I think so I
think so but you know it's it depends
depends on the person okay what do you
think
if the guys are not
he's probably stuck with like what 10
people in his life about 22 Yeah Yeah 22
a girl sorry oh go yeah for a girl yeah
it depends on how many relationships
she's been in but let's say she's been
in like three relationships I want to
see my body comes free but it depends on
the goals you know what I'm saying they
might close to here their mic
can you not hear me bro yeah we can't
hear you probably cool let's say let's
say the girl was like serious well I'm
spooky
move it up move it up yeah there you go
anyway if the girl's like serious about
our relationships and she lost it to a
guy that she's in a relationship with
don't understand like if she's had like
three relationships four relationships
other team like three four but most
girls they get into a relationship yeah
I say the average chick the average
chick yeah 22.
that's what I'm saying five Jonathan is
that from personal like experiences
I'm saying the average should be five
and it is five Jonathan because you're
the boss man
okay what what about you you said that
22 Yeah 22. I think at least 20 plus I
think once a girl hits the club her
number skyrockets
a
so question for the girls
have you ever lied about your body count
no actually never you've always told the
truth yeah has like I ever asked you
um
I think it's come up in conversation but
no one that I'm actually seeing No
actually that's a lie yeah they have
asked me but it's not like it wouldn't
be the first question okay maybe like a
couple months in and did you tell and
you told them the truth yeah yeah okay
what about you
yes you have lied yeah what did you tell
them it was
we do not speak on that but um
let's just say I said it was five but so
if body count doesn't matter why'd you
lie because at the time
my ex was quite judgy and I thought it
would break up with me if we found out
how many people right did he believe you
no I told him at the end oh you told him
yeah yeah did he stay with you or no
yeah okay so he did accept it yeah
yeah I felt disappointed he was
disappointed yeah
well it is what it is okay what about
you so back in the day I did actually
used to lie I can't lie but now I'm very
open about it I don't care what people
think about me I'm very expressive but I
have lied in the past about my body
count but I'm not ashamed about it what
did you say it was like 10 20 10 20 yeah
and what do you will you say what it is
you seem open to saying it if you want
yeah I'll say it's probably over
100.00
maybe or 80 I don't know wow
I'm just wondering how do you go through
that and like how how do you meet 100
men you want to sleep with
I just enjoy life like I'm going through
a lot of experiences I go on holiday I
do all these things and I'm just
thinking why should I care about what
people think you're just jealous you're
living because yeah you're not living my
life
like
[Music]
let's say you meet a girl of 100 plus
that was judgment I want to bother you
no
100 plus it's like
stretching alcohol Jonathan no I think
if she wants to have fun she can have
fun to do what she wants to do a man can
do I've never caught an STD from that I
have ones yeah but that's that's normal
like you would out of all them people
you can't imagine I own that I'm not
gonna lie right you know what I mean
what's the point I'm not gonna be honest
of course no I appreciate you being
honest but I'm just thinking like
but that's a hundred how like but
there's so many people out there that
have got that body count but they won't
own up to it I know plenty of people out
there really with that amount how common
do you think it is what percent of girls
have slept with that many people
probably over 60 to 70. I reckon
there's a lot out there but they just
won't own up to that you're just
experienced it's even better exactly I
don't care what people think and that's
why I'm in the place I am now because I
don't care but don't you think that you
should care about what the man you want
thinks yeah but I'm not in that right
head step headspace right now to care
what that man thinks because I'm
enjoying my life so you're focused on
yourself yeah very focused so when do
you think you'll be ready to focus on
the man
maybe when I'm like 30. I'm 24 now so
that's six years that's six years for me
to enjoy it you gotta understand the way
you're living now I'm not judging you
I'm not judging you no good job
a lot of people you said like 100 plus
on average right all right so you told
me in six years what would that be
yeah but what yeah when did you lose
your virginity I'm just like calculating
this per year 16
so 16 you said you're 24. it sounds
really bad me saying that that's just
average I'm not saying it was literally
over a hundred but like so there has
been a lot of yeah it's been an estimate
and I have had a lot of experiences and
I will never regret how I am as a person
and how I even I am about it as well
what's the most people you've slept with
in like a week
probably only three or four
I think what do you mean only three
minutes I'm sorry I don't mean this is
so crazy to me and I know people who
have been looking at me online and
thinking oh what a slag but people do
this as a living as well you've got to
remember that like just enjoy your life
and be who you are as a person and if
you if you like having sex all the time
then go and do it and be open about it
would it bother you if like the
consequence of that would be not being
able to get married later
you yes I know because I do want to be
my wonder I want to have children so you
have to think about what the man wants
what I was yeah I'm a very selfish
person I want to enjoy my own life and I
don't think about things in the future I
just think about at the moment I'm in
right now
but I understand why I understand it but
I think that the goal for every woman is
to get married and have children and
create a family one day right yeah so I
understand that you live in your life
you're enjoying yourself 100 I I agree
with that you should 100 do that but I
also think that you should think about
what the man that you want
is going to think about a woman that has
such a high body but what if he was the
same as me though it's not the same like
we just spoke about that earlier about a
man having 200 men and women aren't the
same like men care about that stuff
women don't well I'll give you I'll give
you an example um would you would you
guys rather like I'm gonna ask you as a
question would you rather have a virgin
or a guy who cheated on you or cheated
on his ex-girlfriend in the past
that was a tough one be honest bro be
honest well God that is a virgin yeah a
virgin you'd pick the Virgin over a guy
that cheated in the pick half a cat but
I'll take your word
I would probably take the cheetah you
know yeah
experience have you ever dated a cheater
okay
so you
want some level if you keep dating us it
seems like that's my time yeah
because you're a pretty girl you could
date anyone it's not like that what do
you mean I wish I wish they just treated
me right maybe maybe you like the ones
that treat you bad yeah I think so too I
think that's my type I really do think
that's my type yeah
but that's what it means so you're not
picking the you're not picking the guys
that are virgins you like cheaters yeah
I'm I guess so but
I would like a man you know there's a
virgin and like man would you rather
have a girl that's a virgin or a girl
that cheated on her boyfriend in the
past a virgin
of course why is that even a question I
don't know you know I'm not gonna lie I
feel like
would do I don't know what do you mean
don't know bro just like just because
she's a virgin I mean like there's a lot
of experience with someone you like I've
gone through so much experience I've
cheated I've been loyal I've done a lot
of things and
with someone who's a virgin I won't be
able to kind of communicate like that
with
yeah hold on hold on hold on hold on
because you can create that experience
with her because if she's a virgin she's
more so she can cheat but cheat on me no
no no no no no no no no
she's more likely to move to what you
want okay so if she's a virgin okay
she's more likely to please you the way
you want how many people are with the
very first people they've ever been with
are you are you I'm looking and look at
that look at you but look at the result
of it look at look at the outcomes in
society that that's led us to and a
hundred years ago only 15 percent of
women admitted to premarital sex so 85
percent of women didn't admit to it even
if they're liars and we double it let's
say it's 30 that's still two out of
three that were virgins people stayed
married back then they don't stay
married now okay what results has that
yielded in society but there's a lot of
relationships that they've been together
for years but they're they're unhappy
Hey brother what would you want would
you want we're not actually like what
would you want what would you want
because you you I'm telling you now you
would not have a girl that yeah she's
been dipped down like she's not been
[__] down or she's not no she's
everything you want but if she don't
love you how you want you won't have her
bro it's as simple as that girl let me
tell you something let me tell you
listen Bob listen
okay a girl that's been [__] on by how
many men won't love you the same yeah
it's not it's not good people
yeah no it can't be like that because
look let me tell you something it's your
virgin girl
virgin girl yeah she'll love you more
cause you're her first then a girl
that's already had like previous
Partners in the past but over the news
but how about this there's this big
thing about this obviously she might
love you but
there's a whole life she has to live and
there would always be that Elementary
there's always that element of like I've
never tried anything different so what's
wrong with that why do you have to have
a variety why can't you just pick one I
believe and that be it I wish I could
answer that question have you had a
variety yeah that's life anything
of course that's not the question that's
not the question what men want the
question is do you want a virgin or a
girl that's been ran through totally be
honest as a man you want a girl that's a
virgin that's it's a simple she because
she's easy to to mold and she's easy to
teach I want you want a woman that
you're able to teach and give
experiences to you can't give experience
to a girl that's been here that's been
there because she's [__] with this
dude and that dude that's not how it
works
listen I'm cool would you want to go
with us run down by different
would you want a fresh go that's fresh
to you only to you you're the only love
of my life only you've had sex with her
you know what I'm saying would you know
what the set the stats back him up if
you're if you're a virgin on your
wedding day you have an 80 chance of a
happy marriage if you slept with more
than five people it drops down to a 20
chance there you go of marriage exactly
what I'm saying of being in a happy
marriage yeah you're much more you're
more likely to be on antidepressants if
you have a high body count you're more
likely to you're more likely to
um it's like have anxiety like all of
the negative things for women are
associated with having a high body count
and that's a fact why do you why do you
think that is why yeah why do you think
that is do you think it's comparison no
I just don't think women are meant to do
it I mean historically historically like
historically women have had to be with
one guy in order to get resources like
they've always been looking for the best
guy they can get and they stay committed
to him but it's like men have always had
a variety it's not the same how can I
ask is that is that fact for women or
for men and women now it's for women
just for women that's right it'll be
interesting to find out the ones for men
um
let me tell you something the more women
they sleep with the more experience they
get you know what I'm saying the more
I'm not a life experience they get bro
let's say cool I'm not gonna lie I've
had more fun in the bedroom of a girl
that slept with more men and that's just
being a little more
you want to have a lot of fun in the
bedroom right with skirts you want to
have fun with them but cool we're not
scared to die why would you call them
skirts because they wouldn't enjoy them
skirts yeah because they are yours
that's what you're telling me though
cool so you have sex with multiple guys
right yeah multiple guys on a lot on a
weekly basis yes Jonathan used to yeah
I'm better now yeah you're better now
anyway but if it doesn't matter how are
you better it can't be better or worse
it doesn't matter I just feel like I've
matured a lot over the past year and
also been on next on the beach has
changed me a lot
um
do you guys feel better about sleeping
with a lot of men or having one go
specifically job sex with to love to
take care of yeah that's that's lovely
yeah one guy one guy well I haven't
found that connection one guy I haven't
yeah but that doesn't mean you have to
go through like having sex
it's not the same thing I go through bad
girls to find the world
no I don't think you do I think the
happiest women that like I know a girl
that waited until she was married and
she was a virgin on her wedding night I
didn't really like you don't know Manny
anymore and it was beautiful like I oh
shoot my cousin did I know too I know
too no and both of them are literally so
happy like they're so in love and I
respect and they're both and the thing
is they're both married to ever well one
one is an average guy one's a slightly
above average guy but they don't know
anything different and that's the
problem when you sleep with a bunch of
guys like your standards go up because
you think going like that about that guy
like that about that and then and then
you start to like look for a guy that
doesn't really exist where the Virgin
it's like the very virgin's happy with
what she has yeah yeah I don't know any
difference what do they say comparison
is a thief of Joy same in a relationship
you know I've got a guy who gets treated
horrible but because that's all he knows
he doesn't know where else to go
there's nothing that he can get better
because that's all he does
women will leave when they're not happy
oh trust me don't you don't have to
worry about women leaving when they're
not happy in relationships so get out of
there so Pearl when you say that didn't
you also say one time that girls love to
be in toxic relationships what women do
in general I would say and what you said
disproves that right well you know
because if they're really unhappy they
will leave
[Music]
it's like what makes them happy is the
is the shin and I think like women we
just like to have some like ups and
downs for whatever reason it's the
unpredictability yeah yeah so it's like
is he gonna flip out on me today yeah
they say they don't like that but
foreign
[Music]
yeah it's weird because when girls like
aren't happy it's like they're happy do
you know what I mean because when like
like when I have friends and they're
complaining about their boyfriends all
the time they don't leave them it's like
when they stop complaining exactly it's
like they like the argument like if
there's nothing there you just get bored
no it's it's just because it's because
it's what you said one of you two said
that you chase bad boys but do you yeah
all right so you know I think it's how
old are you I'm 20. you're 20. so you're
chasing bad boys and that's what you're
going to chase because that's what
attracts you there's a difference
between arousal and attraction what is
naturally attractive is a guy that
treats you nice maybe has a little bit
of status a little bit of money and I've
been through this I've been the friend
where
uh the guy that they were with had more
status than me at the time or had more
money than me at the time but they did
what they did with me on the side why
because I aroused them I gave them
something that that man couldn't yeah it
was attractive to them that that man was
able to give them Security money
stability status but me mentally being
able to stimulate them and talk to them
for hours on end and just be sexually
attracted to me to my aura the way I
talk the way I can abduct myself that
was
yeah that's what they turned them on
yeah so I think for women it's the oh
I'm gonna go with what turns me on and
then when I hit 30 and when my value is
lower then I'm gonna go after the guys
that I should have been going at in my
20s when my value was higher and then
you expect that man to settle down for
you because technically you're settling
because the men you really wanted in
your 20s your 20 21 22 23 24 when your
value is high you're going after the Bad
Boys you're going after God with status
and then at 30 you expect the nice guy
to come and play oh yeah she's picking
me no she's not picking you she's
settling because the guys that she chose
in her 20s when her value was high
didn't want her they treated like [__]
they cheated on her shoulder no respect
showed her no attention and then you
expect that man to be like oh what I'm
proud
it's not how it works you have that's
what I talked about in your 20s like it
matters you have to like think about
what the man wants but then you can't
live just me hold on hold on
you can't just live just me I'ma live my
life I'm gonna be proud I'm a party I'm
gonna sleep whoever I want I get that's
what you want to do you want to be free
you're liberated cool I support that but
at the same time if you want a man
that's gonna marry you in your future
you should be thinking about how you
move and the way that most modern women
move shows that you have no thoughts
about what the men want what the man
that you want wants you only care about
yourself because you just said I don't
care yeah you said that yeah I admit
that exactly so why would the man care
about you
yeah
I have a question why do you want to be
married because if you're a selfish
person it seems like marriage just
wouldn't be for you
um sometimes it feels like you just have
to and I apologize I apologize for
freezing in the beginning it's my first
podcast I got a little bit nervous
looking at Pearl and I was stuttering I
had a speech I prepared I apologize
that's not what you want to get yeah
you're okay yeah you're not gonna get
that yeah so why why do you want to be
married
it sounds like crazy but just a whole
thought of the glamor side of it again
I'm being selfish the whole look of the
wedding being in that white dress but
then I'm just thinking about myself
again and it's poison and I admit that
no that's what they say women women want
the mirror the wedding they don't want
the marriage yeah because being trapped
down that terrifies me but why are you
looking at it as trapped like what what
about it because I'm damaged or I've
always been a free spirit ever since I
was a child I always do what I want so
if you're aware of that why don't you
try to heal that yeah but maybe I will
get into that process but still now I am
that free spirit until something happens
to me and I'll be like okay maybe I do
need to change that all right and I
empathize with you because I've been
broken and yeah I've been there before
so what I said I genuinely mean is I'm
not judging you but what I'm saying is
if you're aware enough to realize that
okay I'm broken I've gone through things
in my childhood and it's made me the the
person I am now okay but once you're
aware of that you have the obligation
and responsibility to be better than
that yeah yeah because because I've I've
let a heartbreak my first ever
heartbreak I've let that destroy me turn
me to an evil person that hated women
I've done that and I and I learned from
that and you know what I told myself
never again
I'm gonna be better it's me I've been
broken in multiple relationships so be
better be better now not later listen
now Javon is showing too much listen
mama how could she be better bro
I I I'm not a teacher but I will give
you some advice from my personal
experiences of a feeling you know like I
said it starts with awareness for one
which I think I've I know you know
because I am broken 100 and and that's
fine there's a lot of broken people I've
been broken before I'm not judging what
I'm saying is that when you realize that
you are broken you have a responsibility
to yourself your well-being mentally
spiritually physically to fix that
and you have to hold yourself
accountable because you can't point the
finger at the guys that broke you yeah
it's me that's responsible at the end of
the day there are pieces of [__] for
doing what they did 100 I'm not saying
like don't hold them accountable but you
have to hold yourself accountable over
them because exactly because every girl
that broke my heart guess what I don't
give a f i don't give a crap about that
because you wanna know what I entertain
that I saw the songs not experience and
think I can be positive about this and
actually realize that it's a good thing
in a way you turn it around oh 100 like
I said in my field message in the
beginning because I I didn't think I'd
be nervous but I was looking at bro I
was nervous all knowledge is given
through pain and understanding you have
to understand what that pain was there
to teach you when you put your hand on
on a um when you're a kid and you don't
know nobody and you're just playing
around and you put your hand on the
stove and your mom now you know now you
know the Lessons Learned but you can't
learn the lesson and continue to make
the same
and then get on Instagram social media
talk to all your friends and play victim
and say I don't know no better you know
better you've been hurt before so why do
you continue to put yourself in the same
situations talk to the same people put
yourself in the same environments that's
going to lead you to the pain that
you're saying that yeah I don't like so
when it when I talk about healing and
I'm generally trying to help you because
I because I understand the reality of
women and honestly in reality men
there's a lot of broken people out there
and I and if there's anything that I
want to get forward to this podcast and
a message is that you can you can heal
yourself
I'm talking about literally 100 you can
heal yourself everybody talks about
trauma everybody's talking about
depression everybody PTSD everything
struggling everything on you right now
if you dedicate this a year [__] social
media [__] your friends I don't
respectfully how do you heal a hundred
bodies hold on I'm gonna get to it I
need you I need you to reel it in a
little yeah I'm a reality I'm a reality
you're going for a while so I'm a
reeling it so 100 the the the the real
thing with the dude would be just be to
be honest which I've done on this
podcast I've opened up it's that woman
that's been with 100 men yeah if you're
a woman that's been with 100 men the
next thing to say to the man that you're
interested is in look I I've made these
mistakes look accountability I think is
the number one trait that men look
forward to in women because yeah we can
judge you off your past that's natural
trait for men but if you don't have any
accountability We're Not Gonna feel
sorry for you we're not going to be
interested but I'm telling you right now
if I'm gonna woman that was like yo I
have like 7 500 bodies but you know what
those men didn't deserve me and that was
at a point where I didn't realize my
value was a woman I didn't realize I was
giving away the most pure gift that I
have as a woman
and now I realize that gift and that's
what I'm that's how I'm gonna move
forward
no I respect that listen buff Giovanni
would you work for a girl that has over
100 buddies as you're worth would you do
that
100 bodies yeah over 100 Buddies
uh probably not but then again it also
depends on the the so you're just saying
that what would you expect your woman to
say to you like
no no not sorry because her decisions is
her life and she shouldn't apologize for
any decision that she makes just like
I'm not gonna apologize for any decision
but I make but I think that there's
there's a point in your life where you
have to be accountable and you have to
be honest and if you've slept with a
hundred men you can never take that back
okay
Giovanni Giovanni would you accept that
your wife how's that slept over a
hundred man would you accept that in
general no you mean General
subject no because like I said there is
this thing that's connection and one
such thing is
why don't why don't you see it as an
issue what's even like with 100 yeah
like you know because I'm just saying
you live in real reality you know men
care about that stuff
right yeah so how because you don't
think that could possibly be an issue
later
yeah it might be but I never look at
anything negative in life like I just
feel like
what's the point because you're just
gonna get down by it anyway you can't do
anything about it at this point what's
the point I can't take back what I've
done so but what's the point just saying
if a girl when it was black what 16 17
when you lose your virginity I mean I
wasn't educated on about self-value and
what it meant to give like your body to
someone so as a young lady if you're
sleeping with people from I mean I lost
mine at 17. I didn't have the knowledge
that I have now that's than I did then
so if you're a young lady having sex
when you're older you might look back
and think oh maybe I shouldn't have made
them choices because now I'm more aware
of the consequences so I think it's a
bit difficult to say oh I wouldn't do
that I wouldn't marry someone who said
with that many people because they could
be a completely different person
exactly I'm glad you brought the point
because broken you're 100 correct
I personally would not but when I said I
think it I think that's something I'm
talking about just for the general man
because like me like would you advise
someone to do that to marry a girl with
100 bodies I mean I I encourage people
to follow their heart like I don't think
follow their heart because
what are you talking about so you're
telling me that's right you give advice
to someone to follow the heart if they
want to sleep with or get married to a
girl that's had 100 buddies in our past
yeah bro if they love them I know what I
would I know what I would and wouldn't
do
it I wouldn't do that but at the same
time
which one is it bro listen
bro what job would you know would you go
for a girl with 100 plus bodies or would
you know me personally yes I said no I
already answered your question so what's
your argument about no it is not arguing
are there or are there out there that
would accept it
and I said they asked me what the woman
in their position would do and I said
the best thing that they could do is
admit to their wrongs and tell the man
that they're interested everyone should
follow their heart boom you're saying
this right yeah for a guy to get married
to a girl that's got 100 plus bodies you
think that's right that's what he
brought an opinion
you're putting your views on other
people I'm not respectfully I don't
respect your opinion
but I'm not doing that I like I agree
with you me and you on the same page as
far as not accepting that but I'm not
gonna put my views on other people and
tell them not to accept that if they
choose that that's what they choose to
do and then the result today is
if you like if it's someone you care
about you would like my blame my brother
right oh yeah I'm saying okay in general
but if it's like family yeah that's one
yeah
wait wait wait wait sometimes if someone
if it's someone you care about you would
tell them not to do that but yeah we're
always talking about people we care
about or people in general I mean people
in general but but I mean you know if
it's good advice you would tell them not
to mess with someone like that no no
offense but let me tell you something
new sorry about people cool so we're
gonna get married yeah listen you're
gonna get married yeah cool you're gonna
have kids right yes
yes sir cool so it's your kids here
they're gonna ask you where did you meet
Mom like where did you meet her you're
gonna say oh after she sucked how many
dicks off the shot how many Sexes that
sexual comes with you know what I'm
saying
Like a Virgin is always funny
so you can't say that that's really bad
because you can't just look at a girl
and just think oh the only thing that
you've done before me is saying sexual
do you get what I'm saying
what if she slept with 80 guys but it
hasn't been in the last two years
yeah if he has a choice between a girl
that's a virgin or a slept with 80
people who would you tell them to pick I
think it generally
same girl please don't say it depends
that's what the women do doesn't matter
Okay it definitely depends on how he
feels if he loves the girl that's more
of a virgin or loves the girl that slept
with me okay then that's the one you
should go what about when I give you
view the data and I say hey he has an 80
chance of a happy marriage with girl a
and he has a 20 chance of a happy
marriage with girl B does that switch
your opinion or do you it doesn't
because the statistic or some kind of
stuff there's multiple studies so it's
not it's not just one they've done it
different like sometimes it differs by
maybe ten to wait by 10 to 15 but it's
similar okay I think as you're aware of
yourself every relationship is different
so I think to compare it or to judge it
I said the same the same girls one girl
has 80 one girl has zero who are you
telling your brother to pick the one you
care about the one that he loves the
most yeah
talking about this stuff like
relationships aren't about being happy
it's not about love like relationships
are not about love it's about it's about
building a family and staying together
it's not it's not bad how can you build
a relationship in a family without love
or someone
but why should that matter
people do it all the time like the
arranged marriages have great success
rates like it's actually really really
high when you look at it those are
people that don't even know each other
like how does it legally let's think
about let's think about the results
right now we're in in a society where we
date before we were getting married and
before before like a hundred years ago
people would date for like three weeks
and then get married what has better
results it's very beautiful by the way
yeah because I don't know any different
[Music]
um
that's not a bad thing because what they
say comparison is the thief of Joy so
it's not a bad thing to not know any
different and being happy but I do admit
you know being in with with a lot of
guys it does damage you thank you it is
poisonous thank you but I'm not saying
that it's a bad thing and I'm glad that
person I wanna so you said it does
damage you so yeah so you can understand
why guys wouldn't want to date girls
that are dancing because it brings it
brings problems into the relationship so
so even if you had a brother and he had
two girls and one had 80 and one had
zero if you loved him you would tell him
zero because you know what that does
because one guy can do that to you
though one guy can damage you right but
what okay but if you have 80 what are
the odds that it's more than one come on
80 you didn't get five for heartbreaks
you feel different to every person
though I feel like you won't feel the
same to all of the 80 men out of the 80
they might be two that you actually love
right
my marriage shouldn't be about that it's
about Duty
it's about a few things I don't think
you can say marriages is just about one
solid thing I think it's about a few
things mixed together and it all working
simultaneously for it to actually like
work and have a successful marriage
oh who do you think will be more loyal
yeah yeah
an argument a proper argument yeah yeah
so you plus body girl yeah yeah or the
Virgin girl which one would rather go
off a lot second of a dick because she's
had so many times before you might be
the one that's gonna change it
you need a guy to be the one I think
through her experience she can realize
actually from my future and for what I
want I want to change my life in that
way I generally think you cannot pick
you can have a judgment on a girl being
okay cool but that's to you it don't
have to be shared you don't have to go
girls are allowed to want men that make
money right he's allowed to want women
that haven't slept with a lot of people
let's say yeah so you're telling me bro
you'd rather go with a girl that's had
80 plus bodies than a virgin that's
fresh to you you're telling me you've
ever go with 80 plus 40. I do not mind
if you as long as you love her this one
is that what you're telling me bro no I
think it's not as black and white as
that I just generally don't think what
do you think about me personally loving
a girl isn't as black as white as how
many bodies you slept with this is cool
I'll get married to the Virgin yeah yeah
listen bro listen listen bro Michael
every time she's on an argument with you
she'll go suck another dick but me I've
got a fresh version that's only a sex
with me
easier you know what I'm saying cool so
look you're telling me buddy kind of
tomorrow right as long as you love her
as long as you love her bro in the back
of your head when you're sleeping with
her
too much she's done this with 80 other
girls bro
I'm gonna say secure it yeah
actually I have a question has a guy
ever been bad in bed and have you ever
thought of someone else no I've never
thought of someone else but I've been
have you ever thought that it was bad
yeah and how would you know it was bad
because I've had others that were better
exactly excuse me
but how would you know what you like if
you didn't know any different because
surely like if you let's just
so if you like how Everyone likes to be
pleasured differently so if they're
[__] you wrong you just guide them
through it oh like this is what I would
prefer if you could do that and you were
because you do want a guy that you have
to guide through it I mean yeah because
you get to know everybody would you
prefer a guy that you would guide
through it or would you prefer a guy
that knows what he's doing I think oh
God to be honest like what okay the best
sex you ever had was it a guy who knew
what he was doing or a guy you had to
guide through it a guy who knew what
they were doing well the best sex I've
ever had yeah was when I flipped the go
upside down ya in my arms that's showing
a bit easier bro she loved it it's not
like she oh dude it's broken dude that
Birkin oh please don't do this do this
way do that way like allow yourself bro
are we talking about as a man you need
to know what you're doing bro easiest
wherever it's your One Last Stand
wherever it's your average goal they've
got to have that done listen what I'm
doing about it you know what I'm saying
hold on hold on there's a there's a
point that an interesting point that I
think that everybody skipped over nobody
nobody commented on it
she said the fact that if a man slept
with 80 80 people
that you might be the one you should
agreeing with that bro hold on what did
Pearl say beginning no I did not agree
with that
the beginning of the show Pearl said oh
if a guy slept with 200 guys I would
like I wouldn't think that he'd be
willing to settle down for me you see
the mentality difference when a woman
slept with 200 bodies she's looking like
oh the man should be like okay well he
should believe that I'm ready to settle
down because he's that special needs
that one but the woman's perspective
from Pearl was if a man slept with 200
bodies I don't think he'd be willing to
settle down so you see the mentality
difference and how it matters no but
everybody skipped over that fact but it
doesn't repulse me like the same way
like when guys hear a high body count in
general it repulses them
and and you Evol you all know that
innately because you also most of you
said you've lied about it I think I
think wait wait wait wait and so that
but for me it's like it doesn't repulse
me I'm just like the odds are not in my
favor but you know but but it's the new
normal yeah I'm talking about the
expectation right a girl that slept with
80 guys oh you're you're right like
Bergen's talking about yeah you're
saying the expectation is he should
understand that I'm giving my attention
in my loyalty my sexual exclusivity to
him and by doing that he should
understand that he's the one but from a
woman's perspective I don't think it
would like you said from your
perspective I don't think that is the
same it's a it's a complete difference
if I move a girl and she stepped with
200 men and she's let's say loose like
that could be whatever it is but when
she's with me
it's completely different but why
because she would respect the love that
she has for me and it'll be different
that's how it works it's not that's how
it works
again
I'll be surprised if you don't get
divorce bro I'm I'm just being over the
girl that has 200 bodies
and you will see what happens all right
I'm just being I'm just being what's
gonna happen if I'm a virgin
possibly happening
it does it doesn't make it you're you're
seeing whether it goes a virgin or not
makes who they are that's completely
fools
baffles me about you it's like I could
give you numbers on it no no wait wait
you you wait it's like I can give you
numbers on it let's say virgins are
better choices for wives
virgins have worse outcomes and there
are multiple studies from different
places around the world and you still
have the same opinion it's like weird to
me no I think you could find statistics
anywhere personally
um and I think at the end of the day
when it comes when it comes to real life
just anecdote every situation is
different and we can always stop just
anecdotally you know that the the women
that sleep with more people
um you know they don't have happy
relationships
this is why I think like men like you to
be honest like respectfully but it's
like you lie to women and that's like
because because you guys always do this
you say you don't care but the woman you
guys pick is never that you don't guys
don't pick that's you just assuming no
because I see it I see it happen
let Mom in here pick a skirt get married
so I have kids with her unless you ends
up the fact that it's using the term is
already it's already
so you're basically saying that I'm a
high
a girl a guy that sleeps with a lot of
girls Jonathan
no a girl that sees a lot of guys
so say it's the other way around then
and the guy sleeps over with over a
hundred he's like okay it's not the same
thing
if a guy can never be a hoe because this
is yourself
when we think about guys we think about
them cool they're a bit like they look
at all the girls this and that what do
you think about a girl from the ancient
times she stays the one why is it all
about girls though why can't we aim it
on men
the world doesn't care if you do what's
easy it is easy as a woman to get sex I
could walk down the street and say have
sex with me and there'd be ten takers
but but a man it's hard for him to get
sex
wait the world looks up to what's hard
to get sexier like it's not valued if
you have sex or not because it's easy
but for a girl if she protects her
energy protects her like
having sex with other guys that makes
her more valuable Jonathan because
everyone wants you and when you like
disappear from that
then you're gonna be more valuable
because everyone wants you we're not
having I agree
but when a guy every like not everyone
wants him but if you can get into the
circles that can get him to have a lot
of [__] then he's valuable as well
Jonathan he's out of the opposite you
know what I'm saying you said that you
don't agree with um us calling women
hoes but if a hoe is someone that slept
with a lot of people what else would you
call it no because it's only referred to
the female like it's cool if if that's
what her is then cool men hoes as well
simpleless
[Music]
Super Chat
okay guys stop interrupting
thank you
um I forgot even what I was asking
um yeah so wait why do you why do you
find that offensive because I think I
was actually wasn't talking about I was
taught wait I wasn't talking to you I
was talking to her because she really
not said it yeah so what was what did
you say um you said that you think it's
like offensive when men call women hoes
so I'm asking why because why should we
have a name for what we do but when men
say men okay if a guy's a plumber you
call him a plumber but it because I've
mentioned that I've slept I've got a
high count and I'm sitting right next to
you it feels like it's aimed at me it's
not though it's not but it feels like
that listen listen you prefer my choices
what's the problem guys what's your
preference like Rich too handsome
Personality yeah
let's say he's like a waiter here he's a
broke boy waiter someone that's powerful
he's got a personality yeah he's got
powerful you know what I'm saying he's
nobody no one knows and no respects him
you won't go for him right no you're
going for the strong guy you know what
I'm saying of course that has experience
that got us rich he's strong you know
what I'm saying same with us we go for
girls that our own experience that have
no body count except from us and you
can't you can't blame us yeah you can't
blame us for that I've just never looked
at it in that way do you know what I'm
saying because you have preferences but
you have preferences and when we call
you a hoe like same words you calling
the guy oh I want to go like I want to
go yeah
you don't find that offensive
I mean they put it in the media I don't
want no scrub like you can probably get
broke in the media yeah
I'm talking about
this guys oh cool
you stop talking
you have to talk talking over me bro
stop talking so that's when I started
actually both keep interrupting him I'm
gonna let you go anyway you made me
forget what I was gonna say Giovanni
they go with us a skirt we can call them
let's get in peace just like a girl come
cool way broke and a guy that works in
McDonald's like ah [__] him [__] that
you know what I'm saying easier
now don't start talking about goals of
100 plus body count no I can't be asked
for it because the thing is whenever
guys have a standard it's like women
shame them for it I mean once you see
this it's kind of hard to unsee it it's
like because if a guy says he wants a
girl that's thin what do we call him
fat phobic
I've never heard of that you've never
heard of it
that's the first time I've had it okay
okay
um but if a guy wants if a guy wants a
girl that he says isn't a hoe it's like
then we shame him for saying that she's
a hoe if a guy if a guy says he wants a
girl that that's
like whenever guys say they want have a
standard it's like women always shame
him for it but I think it's perfectly
acceptable for a guy to be like do you
know what you slept with Bagels that's
kind of ho-ish but we have to be as men
understand that it's the same back 400
bucks
wait but that's not that way you're not
saying
because it's not because
Jesus Christ
we finish okay you're gonna have to go
if you keep doing that okay okay
um no because it's not the same it's
like what women want from men and what
men want from women is not the same so
you can say oh it should be equal but
it's not and like no girl is sliding
into Drake's DM saying oh I wonder what
his body count is they don't give a [__]
[Music]
there's just a study that came out from
girls that have been on only fans saying
that 75 of them have had issues from
doing only fans men do care about purity
they do okay but well I will say that we
can both agree only fans is the kind of
thing that where people have been
exploiting themselves to a an average
degree can you not agree what makes you
think that bro bro are you one are you
fans are you on any fans showing your
butt in your head I'm a manager bro what
are you are you on the only phone show
in your body I'm saying are you one only
fans showing your body I'm a manager and
I understand what it goes going through
tell me what I said no but are you doing
I'm saying are you soon if you listen so
he's he's telling you that he he manages
girls that do only fast all right no 100
but that's completely irrelevant what
are you saying then Rosie brother you're
just shouting bro I can't talk
go to the next question please what are
you saying about only fans girls I think
he was asking you a question all right
what's he asking me I don't know thank
you I was saying would you do early fast
no if you're a manager why would I do
anything I might go is there a market
I think that the answer is listen it's
not just girls that do it listen a cool
there's a market ferry from right yeah
the majority of the market for only
funds is for girls Jonathan there's more
lonely girls the guys out there Jonathan
there's not too many lonely girls you
understand there's too many lonely guys
that's why the Market's big for women
that do only funds not for guys taking
guys are still gonna watch only fans
yeah would you say I said guys in a
relationship can still watch only fans
I'm not talking about it that's why you
just said I'm saying there's a bigger
audience for girls that do anything than
men that do only phones but they're
still an audience for men so what are
you trying to say about that girl what
are you trying to say that's what we're
trying to figure out what did you ask me
don't tell me anything or God to do
elephants and the girls to do anything
it's the exact same thing for platform
the same way I use Instagram and you use
Instagram it's the exact same thing do
you think if I surveyed 100 men and 100
women and said is body count important
that it would be equal I think it would
depend on where you do the surveys
wait wait
technical depending
on what answer your question I'm saying
and I remember earlier when I said
please don't say it depends I need a yes
or no
do you think it would be equal yes or no
would it depend on December yeah yeah go
on yeah you think it would it would
genuinely is this survey going around
the world you said I can't say it
depends
if it's around the world then probably
no no I would say no okay so you don't
think this is disingenuous
because you're trying to act like men
and women are equal we're not equal no
we're not I'm not saying that we are but
that's what we're striving for do you
not want to be equal but no no they
don't want to be equal to men then I
think that's a bit if I wanted to be
equal to man then I'd want to be a man
it's like women would say they want
equality but they're not lining up to do
the hard jobs I think you deserve I
think you deserve respect without for
you being a woman you don't have to be a
man to to be entitled to you know I
think that respectable people get
respect I don't think everyone deserves
respect yeah no do you think I deserve
it I think if you're respectful you get
respect back yeah you're disrespectful
then you get disrespect back I don't
think it's like just deserved I'll be
polite you know you're polite I'll be
polite back yeah but I don't think it's
like like I think respect is earned
it's how you treat others you should
expect to have that back
whatever it is what what age were you
guys when you lost your virginity I was
17. 17. I was 15. 15
16. I was about 13 14. oh Jesus 13. 14
yeah babysitter
[Laughter]
I'm just being real yeah
babysitter and it's weird because it was
the other way around it would be classed
designed completely different but
because it's a guy it's a very like
traumatized from that or no
um not really but I because you know I
had sex then but then I didn't actually
start having sex when you're in actually
in love in a relationship until I was a
lot later in my teens that's so scary
I'm not leaving a kid with a babysitter
it's [__] yes I was here how did she
like did your mom ever find out
uh I've read that story before though it
is it's a common story I think I was
being babysitted by like my friend's
older sister who brought a friend to
kind of help babysit and it was her who
kind of used to like play with me and my
mate and it got like that and you know
they were like a couple years older
I can't tell it's about fighting for
that probably must be about 16 maybe
yeah so there are a couple years a
couple years older but I still yeah oh I
would kill it some people are sick
you're right if it was your way around
it'd be completely different even if it
is that way around if I if I had a son
and a babysitter oh I would kill her
yeah yeah it's crazy I've heard that
story a couple times so it's very common
yeah it's very cool yeah uh what about
you how old were you when you lost your
virginity
and then I went to a girl's house on my
back on my black bicycle and then she
was like come around I came around and I
went upstairs I shared friends on
downstairs she had friends I was like oh
I'm doing it then it's my first time it
was the first time it's like wait a bit
weight of it I was like I can't wait
yeah but I'll still wait
and then yeah it was like I was kissing
her kissing her and then I was like what
am I gonna do it then she's like wait go
slow I was like how much more slow can I
go about on the sun and then yeah we
ended up doing it it was [__] obviously
but then I went up right I was riding
them back home to my on my back yes
and then I went home slept happily
easiest and I never spoke to her again
this is your husband you never talk to
her again why you didn't like her like
that it's not that it's just like you
know when it's your first time you have
a proper food in love with a girl or you
just like oh what the [__] you just
wanted to lose your virginity yeah
this moment that I probably wanted to
[__] her Jonathan but when I did it I
was like what the [__] is this about
like who was nice whatever but I was
like oh like I don't want her anymore
like you know what I'm saying
oh [__] that now it's too much and they
believe her then she gets upset easier
you know what I'm saying
oh yeah that was my story of losing my
virginity here what was it that like
turned you off
[Laughter]
see how it was like doing it this and
that after I came
no offense to the podcast by the way
after I came I was like you know after a
guy comes he's like he's in love with
her or he's like oh the [__] is this
it's just like it was just too easy you
know what I'm saying I came to a house
one time
the first time coming to our house yeah
I was like oh let me do this right now
quickly of course I'm gonna go like oh
what the [__] is this like the first
time this one okay yeah yeah but she
liked it and she kept texting me but I
had to block her and then we went to the
same school and then she was like
welcome what's wrong brutal just relax
bro relax yourself move away but easiest
don't even look at me easier because the
guy other Foods in love all together his
music too or he goes like [__] this girl
was was there anything she could have
did differently
how do you know you weren't pressurizing
her
what the hell is pressurizing so like
but being pushy yeah
I actually I wanted to hear wait so what
is pressure like just pressuring you
yeah just like you feel like you have to
but like because I don't know I don't
know the situation I'm not saying this
is the situation by the way but like a
girl may be feeling in a way like she
doesn't want to do it but she's kind of
you're kind of going at her like oh you
know let's do it or like hinting and
she's kind of feeling you know what
let's just get over done with whatever
and then then maybe she might think oh
now that I've done it
we can we can carry on but sometimes
that's not the case of course of course
like if a girl feels specialized then
and she's on she'll do it she's not soon
yeah I don't personally think I was
pressurizing yeah yeah obviously I don't
know the situation there's a lot there's
a lot of guys that will go like yeah
let's have sex now we got to do about it
you know what I'm saying I mean that's
that great page you know what I'm saying
I don't [__] with that but if I'm going
to the girl what are we doing it then
come on now what are we doing it you
know what I'm saying and if she goes
like no I don't want to do it then
that's fine on her easier is she was
like cool come to my house on this day
on this time with your bike and
obviously I'm gonna go do it
if that's a word you know what I'm
saying I mean did you both agree to it
like because I'm thinking you'd have to
be
somewhat into it to get to that point
sometimes you don't expect it though
yeah there's situations sometimes our
skulls are delusional so you you get
into that it's weird he takes off your
clothes you don't see it maybe you could
think about like you could be talking
and that guy actually wants to [__] you
but you're you can't have every girl has
that kind of thought in their head that
are like you know he probably wants to
[__] me but I want to get to know him
and yeah like a lot of people die yeah
majority of men like just just want to
[__] mate they'll [__] anything so I
mean let's be real here but um
I don't think they're patient
really yeah if a man wants you he will
wait but the fingers the fingers yeah
the guy she wants you here and you're in
a mood for it like you actually want to
do it but you're holding yourself back
in your head in the back of your mind
they're like oh should I do this yes or
no but you're so like into the moment
like you just don't care you know what
I'm saying you know I want to give it to
him like you don't care I mean if you're
both fair enough
but a guy is like I can't lie guys like
in his head he's like oh he's sure to
Skilled like into himself are you sure
this girl wants it this and that you
know what I'm saying that he thinks
about it as well it's not like trying to
[__] this girl [__] it I don't care some
guys I like that that's predatory I like
I can't learn that's predatory
but some boys don't don't think about
how the girl feels in the situation
especially if they've got it on their
head yeah
the thing is when the gut when it goes
in the moment she wants to do it so much
like she's all like I can't learn I want
to do it so much
I'm in that moment you know what I'm
saying the guy's not gonna hold back
easy as but but if the if the girl says
no to him he's on the back down he's you
know okay no problem baby not
necessarily he'll stroke at her but the
guys that are like that they're not
predators in it [__] them easier but the
guys that actually listen to them they
call it the girl goes like no I don't
want it right now got no problem baby
Joker her make her feel comfortable yeah
but someone like that though someone
like some girls
easy as well Birkin some girls can't say
no
they choose not to say no it's like uh
even even the girls go back and forth
like you've never okay you've never said
no to sex and changed your mind later
no never no what would this the person
at the same time
yeah to be fair I have yeah I said no is
that later I'm like yeah yeah it's
confusing to man I think it's confused
that the woman like like they don't know
what they're into you know what I'm
saying because in the time you're not in
the moment and then give it another
couple of hours you're like oh [__]
sake yeah yeah it can be very confusing
to men because I've been in situations
wait let me finish boys
let me land I'm trying to say that
there's been times with my experience
where a girl's been like no no no no no
but then as time's gone on she's changed
her mind so it's made me think actually
next time I'm with a girl and she goes
no no no no no maybe I should stay a
little longer and she might change her
mind
um that happens bad times do you get
what I'm saying so yeah but then it's
like are you a predator then
[Music]
if you have that knowledge you could be
and be like you know if I wait around
maybe she might change her mind but at
the same time it's like you're trying to
get what you want the same way she's
trying to get what she wants if it's
like a pushy salesman you don't blame
the salesman if you buy it still
um if you swipe your credit card yeah
because it's still your choice and at
the end of the day you could walk away
like I think it's kind of disingenuous
when we go back and say oh he's so pushy
that was like you accepted it you could
have told him to get out but I think I
think it's subtle signs of a goal like
when she's in the moment she actually
loves you she wants to have it with you
but she's that kind of like like scared
about it you know what I'm saying it's
your right to make her feel comfortable
you know what I'm saying you have to go
like cool relax baby just relax easier
but if a girl actually doesn't want it
then you can tell she doesn't want it by
the subtle Sons like nah stop touching
me this is no problem you're not gonna
[__] wait around till you [__] her
bro you understand what are you talking
about I'm just saying you're not gonna
wait around the [__] bro
if she says no and you wait around just
to [__] her like afterwards then you're
a little big you're a [__] easiest like
if she says no Then leave it do other
things over you don't have to have sex
with her Jonathan especially at the time
of her don't exactly exactly but if you
wait there a lot oh I'm gonna get this
girl I'm gonna get a [__] I'm just
gonna wait a bit so she's happy allow
yourself bro you're a [__] man bro
yeah
man do that and they need to get [__]
they need to get put in jail bro are
they saying that's like jail I think
that's a bit extreme just because a girl
changes her mind yeah but it's not about
that let's say let's say it's actions
that's what it is let's say a girl says
I don't wanna have sex with you I love
you and the guy's waiting there
hopefully she change them and hopefully
she's wonderful what if that guy has had
like five other girls that he's tried to
have sex with she said and then and then
you know maybe he wasn't expecting it
but she changed her mind later because I
even have you met guys tell me that like
if they tell a girl okay fine that's
fine no no problem then she comes back
even like harder weirdly enough when he
like takes away the attention so it's
it's like I think saying that he's a
creep is kind of it's a bit far it's not
saying that but if a guy's specifically
done yeah just the [__] her when she
says I don't want it and he waits there
just the [__] her then that's not right
that's predatorial yes yes
I just wouldn't say predatorial like
that acts like you're a child you can
still tell him no and just say go home
like at any point it's just proves that
you don't have any self-control listen
if you can't do it a lot of people can't
do that
does your voice not work I've actually
invited girls to my house and been a bit
like hesitant to be like actually I
don't want you here I want you to leave
but I've been a bit hesitant to say
leave I feel like girls have been in the
same position and book and I've not
actually said you should learn how to
say leave then well like I think it's
like I think I should have put it on the
other person I think a lot of people I'm
just big in like accountability like if
you if you choose to sleep with someone
you can't go back and call them a creep
later in my opinion if you choose to do
it if if you didn't choose to do it then
that's one thing but I'm just not I just
think there's a lot of like me too [__]
that's kind of gone around where we call
them creeps when I don't think they're
creepy but the thing is like if it goes
statistics listening statistics listen
bro I'm speaking bro I'm a podcast I
have to listen well I'm speaking first
bro listen cool let's say a girl's there
and she told you specifically yeah
instead of like instead of like choking
to her whatever you get angry at her
yeah oh I never heard that when's this
girl we're gonna give you six you know
what I'm saying that's the amateur
that's what little nerves do you know
what I'm saying and then like she
doesn't want it and then she ends up not
wanting it because he's angry she he
wants it so much she doesn't get angry
exactly you know what I'm saying but if
even if he's in his headlight oh I Wanna
[__] this girl so much some people just
[__] in the head honestly it's gonna
come across like that you know what I'm
saying but if he's that cool no worry
babies cool it's fun like you I'll drop
you home in a car no problem if you
don't have a car then you shouldn't be
going for girls anyway above don't be
walking around on the streets of women
easier
because I thought you were talking about
the whole thing when you're walking down
the streets I asked I was walking down
the street and then a guy comes up to
you in the car or like we'll start
walking behind you quite quickly yeah
and they're like you're right babes yeah
I don't respect
especially when she's able to get with a
guy I don't respect guys moving to girls
when she's with her man do you
understand I don't respect that I don't
even look at God I don't even look at
guys when the with the girl like I don't
know her girls when they're with that
guy because I don't go like oh she's so
sexy yeah when she's a man that's
disrespectful I wouldn't want to say
anything happening to me easier it's
just you know some respect at the end
exactly exactly when they go like oh um
your boyfriend doesn't have to know
um
I think I think it's about
comfortability because if a girl comes
back to your place
I think it's a kind of a mutual
understanding of what's expected or
what's possibly going to happen and I
think if a girl comes back to your place
and you're vibing and you're doing
whatever you're doing and she says no
I think it's a it's a point of like
comfortability she doesn't feel
comfortable with you if you you she
walks in she takes her shoes off let her
know right there get comfortable
I just don't understand like what were
you doing there in the first place like
is it a girl if you feel pressured or
whatever it's like why'd you go back
exactly because yeah
after a certain hour yeah I just assume
that's that's assumption that's
assumption it's not assumption any one
of you it is if I invited you back to my
place
in your mind I do think that straight
away what's the expectation what do you
think what do we what are we doing what
are we doing yeah what are we doing but
you know are we just
chilling here you know if you go back to
a man's place after you've been drinking
out night on the club with your girls
and I'm out with my boys or whatever
yeah and you come back we know what it
is
you think that you want to be my friend
you know what it is if you're coming
back then you know what the expectation
why am I inviting you back to my place
I'm not gonna lie bro I think that's
your own expectation
wherever girl that I go back with I know
whether we're gonna just chat and talk
or whether we're gonna have sex
we're going to do this
I think you automatically assuming oh if
you're back at my place at this time we
have to [__] right I think that's just
short expectations
what world do you live in I live in the
21st century in London do you know what
I mean do you so you you bring girls
back to your place wait wait wait wait
wait wait
do you bring you you bring girls black
to your place at 2 A.M and
I'm waiting
and what they just curve you
sometimes they have sex with me
sometimes we eat sometimes we do this
sometimes we do that I think it depends
it depends on the girl I'm saying I
think if you're going to be like my man
and assume that every girl you come back
with you're gonna you're gonna [__] your
waste man I'm just being real I agree
bro this guy I don't know what you're
saying how about you my bro you're 20
yeah I'm 28. so I've got eight more
years of understanding
it's about yours it's not about being a
feminists
listen labeling people in a bracket is a
young person bro listen so you're
telling me when a girl comes to your
house 2 A.M you're gonna eat [__]
people don't watch Netflix
you might have it go come back to your
yard at 2 A.M yeah and you know what you
might try and [__] her she don't want to
[__] you then you know what you'll never
see her again when some people might
just wait chill get to know the girl and
in the future they still
finally both
chat
um okay guys make sure you like the
video
um
and ring the notification Bell
um Clint um Clint Torres I'm getting
sent Vibes in the back Amina
um I am uh I am a Muslim girl
um and my cue is from the girls do you
think you being used by many men is
something you can be proud of because of
how happy about it and girl why do you
have a Chris Christ symbol on your neck
if you don't follow his cheat teachings
Clint Jerry Jerry snake yeah they coming
forward
I'm gonna you can respond after I'm just
gonna read them all um 90 Frito pie um
your mom is not a female dog uh to you
but she is to someone else if you can't
see if if you can't see that then why um
can't women then why can't you call
women a 304 I'm Francisco R
um to the younger brother I unders I
understand I believe you're very young
but life will teach you differently why
a virgin is valuable tend to 15 years
from now
um
um Jordan um Purity and virginity is
important to a high value man it's not
insecurity and standards
um Brian um dude guys shut up please you
need to stop 93 to apply for the women
what is he not leaving
laughs
uh for the women on the panel you have
girlfriends right um how would you feel
if your perfect man had slept with every
one of your friends that's how men feel
um Bryant men get out of your feelings
stop interrupting
uh Francisco men are scared of losing
their phone more than or women are
scared of losing their phone more than
their virginity YouTube has lied
um uh has me edited this message
multiple times for no reason if she can
have a body count will she will not
she's through TV per oh wait that's the
wrong that's another stream Let me
refresh it really quick
and make sure there's no new one
okay
um all right
did we talk about okay how many bodies
do you guys think it takes for a girl to
become a hoe
does it exist I don't really have one
obviously because it doesn't affect me
but I think guys say about five
I hear guys say 10 that's like the most
pop yeah like 10 to 15 that's what I
hear what age are you talking about
parents because I think it depends on
the age right
um I don't know I just that's whenever I
ask this question on the street a lot
and that's just the most common answer I
get 10. I think you can only regardless
of age
um I'm trying to think when I've asked
guys about 10 it seems like 10 at 30 is
not too bad 10 at 25 well and to be
honest the guys say 10 they'll usually
like I see who they date you know and so
they really deal with about 20 like to
be honest they just won't like tell you
and I just know because like it you know
I think the ideal would be like four or
five yeah no seven that's what guys like
they want below five that's ideal 10
like 10 they feel like you're a hoe 15
to 20 they'll deal with but that's not
preferred and then after 20 it's like
I've got no height then basically yeah I
know it's really sad
sad for you because if you're a pretty
girl and you're actually very pleasant
but it's like because you've made those
choices I think it's gonna be hard for
you but babe you'll find someone who
doesn't care about that is that like not
everyone actually cares about that yeah
and I think that you know just opinion
did you know like 50 of women are
projected to be single and childless
they've slept with a lot of people
um no just in general I mean I don't
think it's just women that have slept
with a lot of people but they're
predicting half of our generation is
going to be single and childless because
we don't know how to be wives I think
you can only I think aho is when you're
still doing the same things so like I
wouldn't say like let's just say a girl
as a hoe she slept with
let's just say 30 people right but she
hasn't slept with a lot of people for
three years let's say she hasn't slept
with people for three years anyone is
she still at home yeah why because I
think is someone if someone that's been
to prison or they're still a criminal
[Music]
that's the thing so like if a girl is
you know they've grown and they've
learned that's that's immature I'm I'm
valuable and I actually want someone to
love me for me and they don't sleep with
anyone and they wait for the right
person to come I feel like you've grown
and you've matured and have you ever
shouldn't matter have you ever switched
a habit what do you mean like have you
ever had a habit and like you switched
it so maybe you didn't work out and you
started working out or maybe you ate a
bad food and then you stopped yeah and
you know you know how difficult it was
for you to switch that habit yeah like
it wasn't easy and that's the thing it's
just like if you've done that for so
long it's not saying you can't change
some people do but it's just on a
balance of probabilities why would a guy
deal with a girl that has more bad
habits than a girl who doesn't because
she's used to going out all the time
she's used to going on all these dates
if if you've slept with a lot of guys
I'm sure you've been on like super nice
dates at some you know like and and so
now if you meet the average Joe you know
which maybe would have been your husband
how is he going to impress you because
the thing is you've always got it in the
back of your mind yeah not the
materialistic things matter but you do
have it at the back of your mind
thinking oh that was such a nice date
where the sun was going down and the bar
was really nice but now I'm just going
to a regular bar or something and it you
think back at it when you're at that
table at a regular place when I
shouldn't but if you do automatically do
that sometimes and you know I'll be
honest about that but that's just how it
comes I've I've made that decision to do
what I've done
um
and yeah you've just got a no and I and
I appreciate you being honest about it
but like you see how it becomes a
problem yeah you can see what you mean
yeah yeah because it's like with 80 it's
like how many guys did you really really
really like yeah but sometimes you can
get yourself in situations like and I'm
sure sorry
but and I'm sure the guys that you did
really really like like something was
really special about them and it's
really hard to replace that like I think
it's hard for a girl that's up with Five
Guys to replace the one she liked and
you've always got them in your mind
right whatever wherever you are kind of
thing and admit not not even now it's
still like that so the guy how how many
guys are you thinking of when I'm
talking about this probably about five
or six about five or six out of the 80s
it's actually good right so out of the
the five or six the five or six guys
you're like thinking about because you
know when I don't know who they are as
well because no because when I talk
about this stuff I'm sure there's
someone that comes to you guys's head
like there's someone that comes to my
head right but it's like so out of the
five or six guys did you sleep with them
early on or late I'm just curious
um
it was kind of throughout the whole
period actually it was more stretched
out
um but I don't know actually I reckon in
the past two years actually recently
I've had a couple of guys in my life and
that have stuck on my mind
what
no because it's always I always wonder
if like at that point you can still like
Bond at that level where it really
really gets you from yeah yeah but
you're saying like you could because I'm
guessing it's like what at like 50 you
but it just he has to be really really
special very special it'll take me a lot
now I think for a guy to
for them for me to fall in love I don't
think I've fully been in love I don't
know what love is so I admit that oh I
got a question so all three of you girls
really beautiful woman thank you thank
you have you ever met a guy that was
loyal nice
checked off all the the boxes that are
required for you know a long-term
relationship but you looked over him and
chose a guy that you knew was never
going to commit to You Never Gonna Give
You loyalty Never Gonna Get You the
attention and the respect that you
deserved yeah
I have
um
why is that do you know what it is
though hold on why why is it that you
choose the man you know the outcome
let's not act like we don't know when
you meet the attractive guy in the club
he's got a suit on he's got change he's
got listen the most attention I've ever
got from women in the club was when I
brought other women with me when I went
my boys
few looks like there's one more of a gun
exactly so when I showed up with a bunch
of women the attention was unlimited
because you want what other girls want
but my question is why do you choose you
know the outcome this is why I talk
about playing the victim in
accountability earlier when I talked
about healing yeah because there's no
way you could [__] with a [__] boy
and know that yeah but you can't control
that but girls that's what's that's
what's in there no but yeah I know but
the question is why do you choose
which you know the results that's what
they're attracted to well they can't
just choose it I talked about that
earlier attraction yeah they can't help
it bro but I'm trying to get deep rooted
with it if you're trying to get deep
rooted why do you choose the bad guy
over the good guy when you know the
result of both because the good guy can
treat you good and he may not
arrived of the bad boys so don't choose
it in your 30s when your value is less
yeah and expect that means no I think
the best solution is you know I think
the best that's all I'm saying I think
it's about when your most valuable give
your man that value at that because
listen bro listen listen Giovanni cool I
think the best solution is here to find
that bad boy to find that guy that gets
a lot of women and make himself
no really you're not going to change
them every woman thinks that they can
change your mouth and that's a fact
that's excitement that's the examine
when a guy when a girl thinks they can
change their mind that's exciting for
them or I can change him I can make him
mine that's a game
and that's exciting for girls they don't
want a guy that's not something that's
on the PlayStation like [__] playing
games they want a guy that's popular
that's high in demand you know what I'm
saying I like a guy with ambition do you
do you think that's good advice under
the average chick but I would to try to
change a bad boy I think it's like to
find the find the guy that actually
loves you no matter what he does like as
long as he loves you but is that is that
typically that like because usually if
I'm just thinking stereotypically the
bad boy has a bunch of women after him
yeah so like what are the odds that the
average chick is gonna get him but you
don't think for the average chick she
should go for the nicer guys I think I
think like giving myself as an example
like as a Playboy
when you finally go with that you
actually love yeah and she knows that
you whatever whatever you do but you
actually are in love with each other
then it's fun you have a nice long
fulfilling relationship you know what
I'm saying she has a
like interest to change you you want to
be over virgin girl like you take a
virginity easier that's the best aspect
she never gets bored you're happy easier
but if you're with some girl that's ugly
that no one wants her like she's not
loyal or whatever right but but knowing
that women like sleep up is that really
good advice for the average chick
because she's probably sleeping up well
sleeping up most girls sleeping yeah so
so it's like you know only like 20 of
men really get sex like that like 15 20
amounts when you guys sleep with someone
it's probably the top 20 percent of men
and so like why do women think all men
cheat like why do you guys date [__]
because the [__] don't know any
different no no it's because like you
guys want the top tier man and so if
you're dating a guy that's an [__]
guy that's cheating that means he can
cheat one out of three men are either
virgins or haven't had sex in the past
year so if you're going for a guy that's
in the top percentage like he's more
likely to cheat and so that's why I'm
saying like if you're a girl that's a
five or six or seven can sleep with an
eight nine or ten but it doesn't make
you an eight nine or ten and so the
problem is like when you're talking I'm
thinking if she's going for the top 20
percent of guys which usually I would
say they're more of the [__] because
they can be right and a guy's not going
to treat you as special if he's got
multiple like the average chick isn't
gonna slow him down Pearl and I think
it's also the average of what
environment you're in because if you
most women sleep with the guys they work
with so if you look in the workplace
they're everybody's sleeping with
everybody it don't matter where you work
I've worked several jobs wherever you're
working there's girls
that is not that is not the case
in general wherever you and where you
were right right people are sleeping
together because the guy that's sleeping
with all the girls in the campus you
don't heard things about them whether
whatever it is sexual or status whatever
and you know the guy how he is he's a
player he sleeps with all the girls on
whatever job and you still choose to you
still choose to do that but it's also a
sense of maturity if the woman actually
knows like what she wants
then and she's matured in her mind a lot
of us girls are delusional and immature
and we like to go for bad boys because
we were now immature stay that's a fact
as once you've matured and you know what
you like and what you you value what you
like and you value within yourself I
don't know if I'm explaining this
correctly I'm good you're doing good
yeah um
but you I personally don't like bad boys
anymore and I think I was in an immature
era yeah
what you're telling me right now yeah
you ever go for a guy that's not a bad
boy that's loyal right now
a guy with ambition and drive and knows
himself and knows how how he looks after
a woman is so attractive than a bad boy
that doesn't know himself and know how
to dis only disrespect you woman do you
do you sleep who do you sleep with
faster
um what do you mean who do you sleep
with faster that's a good point that's a
very good a bad boy or the good guy
Courtney's very different though she
holds herself back a lot and I have huge
respect for this girl
okay but could you answer the question
because you said you you've dated
cheaters in the past
right yeah yeah yeah and so like the way
men will see it is when you're the
younger you are the more valuable the
like higher value you have as a woman
right you know you know this at some
level if you're 50 and you're 20 you're
more valuable to men at 20. right when
it comes to looks like what they're
attracted to so it's like when you have
the most to give and you have the lowest
body count you choose the bad boys like
the you're kind of seen as like left
over to the nice guys and it's it's kind
of like okay imagine if you if you found
out if you're dating a guy and you found
out for their anniversary his
ex-girlfriend he spent a ton of money on
took around trips did all this stuff and
the most he's ever done for you is
taking you to Taco Bell you'd be pissed
that's how men feel when they find out
you slept with Tom Dick and Harry after
one night but you made him wait a month
or a week shows that you're different
right no okay
I want to be said that to you like oh it
shows you're different I took you to
Taco Bell
that's how guys see it yeah so they they
see it as oh when you were younger
fitter like hotter you you gave your
best years to the bad boys and now it's
like to them now and like they and it
seems like and I genuinely believe those
are the guys that women really want but
once you realize you can't tame them
then you go to the nice guy I don't know
how to feel about that analogy you know
what do you what do you not feel about
it
I don't know like the Taco Bell thing
what she's basically saying is all right
imagine I'm dating
her Layla Layla and I take it to a five
five star yeah so five star dining
and you've seen this you've seen this on
my stories I posted we break up whatever
and then when I take I take you to Taco
Bell
what would you think you're worth when
you've seen me take a woman and treat
her right
you understand are you dating
uh we're just maybe not it doesn't
matter what you've seen okay but you've
seen me take women whether you don't
know if we're dating or not yeah I'd be
pissed exactly so how do you think a man
would feel when he knows that you've
given up in a day or two and then you're
sitting here demanding like oh you got
to do all this you got to jump through
this loophole you got to take me on this
amount of dates you gotta wait this
amount of months so what are you talking
about it's not really is yeah
the girls that will give it to a God and
listen it's not the same thing as like
if they'll give it to a guy like that
waits for like three months four months
you know what I'm saying it depends on
his voice that's not gonna wait three
four months it depends on his valuable
listen it depends on his value let's say
it's a problem
yeah she'll give it to him quicker than
a low value guy Jonathan because in an
instinct it makes more sense to give it
to him quicker Jonathan for a low value
huh he says for a low value or a high
value that's true no I I agree with you
like women sleep with the men like we
like more quicker but that that's the
whole point we're making is like when
when for the bad guy you sleep with him
quick and you make the nice guy wait
attractive but the issue and that's why
I'm like I don't know if I would
encourage women to go for bad boys
because it's like it like what are your
odds of actually getting one at the end
of the day they're more protective
they're more protect they'll protect
them more don't look after him or they
they tend to have money because they're
aggressive they want aggressive in life
they know what they want so they get
money you know what I'm saying that
comes with getting [__] easy years
there's nothing to do about it you know
what I'm saying cool except the fact
there's [__] he's gonna love you for
the rest of his life he's gonna have
kids with you you know what I'm saying
it's a beautiful thing it makes me smile
when like let's say I'm imagining myself
having kids with my girl oh it's very
cute that's so good so what if I just
[__] I'm scared like just like whatever
yeah could you guys deal with that
um a guy that you're having kids with a
family with you're you're his wife but
he has girls from time to time I think
men cheating is the new Norm
I really do like dislike I don't agree
with it at all but
I think all men do it to be honest
whether it's physically or mentally it
could be like oh man
to be honest we've got too much choice
in the world or just the men that you
[__] with well fine
majority of the men
you gotta understand
so you understand your your beauty is is
extremely valuable yeah so let's say
you're I'm not judging you I'm just
saying exactly say you're eight or a
nine you're a beautiful woman yeah you
don't understand that your value is
extremely more than a girl that's six or
seven yeah yeah so the type of men that
you're gonna gonna entertain is gonna be
a different type of level you're gonna
get a lot more attention you're going to
get a lot more interest you're getting a
lot more like chasing than than the
average I go think about this year think
about this cool think about the time you
was most in love with a guy the most
yeah the most do you think he had like
he was higher value than a gaze than to
fall in love with like more money more
production more respect for other people
higher status did you feel like that you
was in love with her more than the other
guys that you had used in love with you
don't think about the money or anything
if you're fully in love with that guy
that's all that matters yeah but yeah
but what makes you laugh in love with
him do you find that a guy that's more
higher value you love him more than a
guy that's some thicker broke boy
someone who's got stability
did you think you love that guy more or
the guy that some broke where that
doesn't offer anything I think it
depends how they treat you I think women
fall in love with like words and how
your children so let's see let's see
something let's say some homeless guy
peasant yeah
Charmed you with his words yeah oh my
baby but you've got to be physically
attracted to him as well who has muscles
he did push-ups in his [__] Street
okay
let's say you spoke his words to yeah my
baby Ashton you're so beautiful
like all my days I can't stand you
anyway it's the
um consistency of it because this is
because any guy at the start they'll
tell you what you want to hear they'll
pick themselves
you're telling me to a homeless guy that
stays consistent in telling you my baby
I love you
why he's homeless but he's homeless be
realistic girls but he's homeless build
with them oh my diesel oh girl come on
yeah
there's some crackheads down the street
I can introduce
you can have Romeo spitting the most
beautiful poetry you've ever heard to
you every single day showing up on time
to dates giving you gifts right if that
man doesn't have something outside of
words you will not give them the time of
day
I hope you don't like come on we should
not be dating broke that is you if you
had a daughter you would not tell her to
date a guy that's completely broke
I think this whole
what is the ambition it's money later
like that's what you mean because he
only has so much time like when we say
ambition that's all it means you have to
make money eventually you're gonna do
something eventually well I'm not I'm
not saying that women like we all need
to date a guy that makes like a [__] ton
of money but like it's like disability
to say to say we can't gold dig a little
bit it's just like it's broke if a rich
man wants to take me out and love me and
marry me yeah
and the thing is I don't think it's
about it's money but I don't think it's
about I don't think it's about money
this is what I'm saying like I like a
man with ambition whether like you
obviously got to have some sort of money
do you know what I mean like because you
can't just be broke and have Ambitions
and you just don't you know I mean it's
a bit lost and you don't know yourself
clearly but like
if you have Drive
I will be ambitious with you and I'll
make sure you get to that place but how
long does that last
because a man can have ambition and do
nothing that's what I'm saying if you do
nothing then you're just giving me words
you're not actually showing me [__] as
like actions let's just say oh I want to
do this and that and I'm sure I'm making
action and I'm making trying to make it
happen so the man still has to perform
so ambition ambition is good is ambition
is sort of a temporary acceptance for
you I'll accept ambition as long as it
leads somewhere yeah but if I'm only
with you for six months to a year and
you have it transform this into
something else then I'm going to leave
you so again men are working hard enough
that's not about working hard some men
just aren't destined to do anything with
delaysia that's the average man and
that's what that's what this podcast
talks about the acceptance of the
average man and why I asked for the
question of the the respect the lack of
respects
listen buff for a month it takes long to
build himself up you know what I'm
saying exceptionally exactly it takes a
long time you can't just get the summer
overnight like you said you're sure you
show an action it's gonna take him a
long time you know what I'm saying yeah
like showing action like Little Steps
Little Steps that's what I'm talking
about I'm not talking like oh you're
willing to wait for like at least five
years exactly seven years eight years no
I wouldn't say five years you get done
now whenever you want to get it done it
doesn't happen though it's harder for a
guy you know what I'm saying like he has
to build them so far get respect let
alone become known be respected get the
money get more money get even more money
where you can look after a family that
takes a long time
listen bro people think
[Music]
19 and you work in some [__]
McDonald's you know I'll tell you not to
get a fan of yo because when you finally
go and you work in McDonald's then
everyone then McDonald's is a threat to
you you know what I'm saying like let's
say that your girl is going through the
drive through and there's McDonald's
workers there they're all a threat above
they're a threat he's yours
because if you would date the McDonald's
worker then you would date another
McDonald's
if you're if you're a top like 10 or 5
guy the odds of him her replacing you is
like what is she gonna do but that's the
problem with like sleeping up you know
what I mean because if you're five or
six or seven and you sleep with an eight
nine or ten now you think you're on that
level and any guy that you date after is
gonna not feel like enough this is why
so many women won't date average men
even though they're average women like
you don't see like there's a there's a
stream where they asked um would you
date a bus driver this is a woman with a
kid and she said no but this girl had a
child so she's below average in the fact
that she has a kid because when you come
into a kid with a relationship you're
immediately below average when it comes
to women it gets difficult from there
yeah yeah because now he has to he has
to deal with your kid and she wouldn't
date the average guy and you could say
you know you don't blame them but like
we don't live in la la land someone's
gotta date average man you know what I
like not everybody
the reality of the world is here your
other broke guy and no one no girl wants
you because let's be real no one wants a
broke guy no matter what he says no
matter what he says to you the programs
the letters anything doesn't matter
nothing much but same as if you're an
ugly yo no offense like no offense to
women yo then you don't matter either
especially if you're fat that's the
worst person
I'm just saying let's be real here in
the average role if in the average road
if you're fat and you're ugly no one
cares about you especially same thing as
if you're broke and you're a guy no one
cares about you it doesn't matter about
your looks but if a girl I've gotta go
and earn that respect exactly exactly
and that's a harsh truth of reality you
have to get used to it so he spoke about
like creating your value and how much
more it's difficult for men you gotta
understand like Birkin you have Twitter
you said right yeah how many files do
you have but nine point something okay
how did it how long did it take you to
get there about six months six months
all right six months that's still solid
bro no it's a solid yeah but but all
right so for all you beautiful women
here on this panel you gotta understand
that you guys don't have to present
anything outside of that to gain 10
times that you can post nothing but
booty pics bikini pics
living your life on vacation and you're
gonna have a hundred thousand a million
followers and you don't present any
personality it's just how we live
there's got hundreds of thousands of
guys liking and commenting on your photo
for nothing but your beauty you have you
look at these IG models they offer
nothing but looks you listen to the eye
hold on hold on they listen they listen
to their lives and they don't say
anything hold on hold on let me chill
there's no personality given there's no
interest given it's just them on camera
talking in a half top two-piece there's
nothing outside of beauty that these IG
models present so the fact that you can
get on camera and just be without
actually showing any value and gaining a
million followers is what Burton's
talking about when he when you have to
grind for me to get a hundred thousand
followers I would have to grind I would
have to present in value women women and
men around the world would have to
connect with the message that I'm saying
it's completely hard
yeah
you post a booty pick right now you will
get tons of likes I can post a video
saying the most empowering thing in the
world
you will be valued by Men actually I
actually agree with you they've done
studies on this where it's like they
have
um a pretty girl saying the same thing
as like a a guy and it's like the girl
always gets more views exactly
of course but yes that's in human nature
but it depends on who you are as a guy
but what I'm saying is the fact that
it's problems yeah but you're coming
into not my point so what I'm saying is
that men yeah give him a second let him
go yeah
but I but it was my point that you were
commenting
go ahead go ahead he made me forget what
I was talking about but anyway okay cool
it's harder for it's a little cool a lot
of girls
on Tick Tock Instagram so it's even
harder for girls and it's even harder
for guys you know what I'm saying it
depends on who you are let's say like
any guy can go on Tick Tock who are they
gonna watch the most
the guy that had the cars that has the
[__] women that has the cash that has
the respect who are you gonna watch the
girls that have the most Beauty you know
what I'm saying so it's getting harder
and harder there's too many guys on Tick
Tock social media you know what I'm
saying it's getting harder for the
average fat guy that's broke to get
famous do you know what I'm saying
unless you [__] never called her
whatever his name avocado or whatever no
one respects my man
I'm confused what you're arguing are you
do you think it's equally as hard to get
big on social media Man versus
performance it's obviously okay okay
yeah but in overall like speaking of
ruly like guys he needs to be a specific
type of man to get big on social media
right for a girl we need to be specific
to how beautiful to get on bigger social
media you know what I'm saying but I do
things I don't think so there's there's
nerds and dudes that are just like
outcasts and socially awkward dudes that
that they thrive in their Lane okay
they're respected
always the ones with
Power Respect uh 100 money and the
biggest the biggest goals in the world
that are most respected are the ones
with beauty looks unless it yeah no if
that's your point I agree 100 there's a
lot of women out there that have huge
personalities and have the looks and
everything as well it's not just about
looks yeah of course I agree what you're
saying but a lot of girls do still have
that power and that personality as well
as their looks
yeah but they don't show that on social
media 99 they don't have to no but they
don't they don't and that's a privilege
right it is great
um sorry guys
I was just gonna say it is good because
like for me personally I'll just post a
picture and get loads of loads of likes
I don't have to use my personality but I
could because I feel like you're doing
your captions though I feel like you're
definitely doing your questions nobody's
reading the captions
what percent of your followers are men
versus women I think mine's 98 men yeah
yeah it is a high percentage yeah um I'm
curious like going back to the virginity
thing if you guys could go back in time
would you wait until you were married
Tough sex yes yeah you would 100 yes
Courtney Barnes
um
do you know what I don't know because I
feel like every every relationship that
I've been in I've I've learned something
from so it's like if I said I'd go back
and change it and not do it then I
wouldn't learn I wouldn't have learned
the things that I wouldn't moving
forward so I don't know it's it's almost
like saying I'm just gonna eliminate
experiences that I've had
yeah but if they ended badly like what
value does like sexual experience bring
to you now
like what you know if you're gonna let's
say you meet your husband tomorrow and
you're going into a marriage and you
could have just slept with him yeah or
slept with him and all these other guys
like don't you think it would be better
to just sleep with him I understand what
you're saying because obviously when you
get married the love that you have for
that person other people that you've
been in a relationship is definitely
different because you're married and
you're gonna build a life with them so I
think when I get to that I'll probably
be like oh do you know what I wish I
would have waited yeah now I haven't I'm
not trying to settle down I'm not in
that time of my life so my perspective
is going to be different what age would
you like to settle down
if I'm completely honest it's all about
when my career is is if one I'm happy
with where I am in my life if that makes
sense because I wouldn't want to settle
down not having achieved everything that
I want to achieve on myself because I'm
kind of quite selfish in that I want to
be very successful do a lot have tons of
businesses so I think so if I I blew up
and I had all this success by the time I
was 27 then cool I'll I'll look for when
I'm 27 but I it depends on where I am
financially and stuff like that to be
honest what value does your career bring
to a guy
well music I want to inspire people and
motivate people and I want to make a
change I want to you're a man don't care
true he's like oh I'm looking for a girl
to inspire and motivate you know what I
mean yeah yeah 100 I think it's like
you're young now you're pretty now and
but you're gonna be less pretty and less
young in 10 years and five years so like
why would you not look for that when
you're younger
I mean I look I look quite young now so
maybe when I'm older I'll still look
young I know I mean but um I just know
what I want out of life yes I I do want
a family for me that's very important
because I don't have any siblings and
all my family members are very far
spread out across the world so for me I
need that security so just just a stat
for you guys did you know if you hit 30
and you and you're still single you drop
to a less than 50 chance of you being
able to have a kid meaning that if
you're still single you're more likely
to not have a kid than have one
and so it's like knowing that you
wouldn't want like because you know
you're 24 now right yeah let's say you
date a guy tomorrow and you date him for
three years and it doesn't work out yeah
it's like then no no now you're a bit
older and you have to keep yeah I do
think everything happens for a reason
though if I'm completely honestly I
could turn 13 find my dream guy the next
day
do you know what I mean and then build a
relationship with you you can't you
could but the odds aren't in your favor
yeah and the number and that's what
that's what I'm saying like I think a
lot of times Society tells us to go
after a career first when it would be a
lot easier if we if we were married
because you could have the same
experiences you could just have them
with your husband
very true but then what if he then
wanted to have kids with you straight
away then you'd have to sacrifice that
and you want to be a mother oh yeah I
want like five kids you know 90 of your
ex ninety percent of your eggs are gone
by 30. yeah so wait wait too long you
can't have five
yeah you're a curious do you know when
geriatric pregnancy starts I need you
34. what's Gerry
you know the answer I was going for them
I said what is geriatric so geriatric
pregnancy is like high risk pregnancy
you know when that starts
I'd probably say 30 30 plus well you
know it's 40 right now
28 it's 35. really yeah so high risk
pregnancy starts at 35. and IVF it's
actually most likely that it won't work
out complications
I'm I'm IVF and I'm an IVF baby my
parents started um trying to have a kid
at 34 I think but I think they had
complications anyway yeah I know and
they're lucky that you you yeah they're
lucky but that's not the norm like the
majority of IVF doesn't work out yeah
and those complications as well so yeah
but we can do stuff like freezer eggs
and stuff like that I know that again
it's it's not 100 but but like you said
but even like the odds are if you're
over it's like it's a less than 50
chance that you eat that that works out
that you actually even conceive the kid
so it's like they kind of lie to us
because they tell them you they tell us
we have all these options when we don't
when half of your options are also gone
by 30. so the number of options you have
at 20 by the time you get to 30 half of
them are gone do you think it's a lot of
pressure on a woman yeah it is it's
actually quite sad like even this
conversation is opened my eyes
you're being told some people are saying
that women shouldn't have a career they
should focus on their marriage and care
about their husband and their children
um other people want to not have
Housewives and want their woman to have
a career but then we have the pressure
of not being able to have kids at a
certain age there's just there's so much
for women to kind of squeeze in yeah it
could be overwhelming
well that's the thing you can't have
everything but it's like what outcomes
do you want like priorities yeah like
what what outcomes would make you happy
everyone has a different priorities
right and so it's kind of a trade-off
because you know women over the age of
45 that are still single and childless
like they're on drugs they're on drugs
at a higher rate than any other group
and they're more depressed than any
other group and they don't tell us so
we're really on a Time clock and and
they don't really warn us about that and
you just you can't have everything and
so it's the question of like what
outcome do you want personally for me
I've had this conversation myself a fair
few years ago actually
um I want the fame and fortune and to
have a career but I need a family right
for my mental health so if I had a pill
one of them was to have a family famous
I would have a family because that's
what I need right right so why wouldn't
you prioritize that now knowing knowing
that the quality of guy you're gonna get
is only going to get worse like right
now that you're the most attractive
you're ever gonna be you know it'd be
one thing if you were fat and then you
could lose weight and get it but you're
in shape right
because they always give me this
exception like because if you're fat duh
but but you know you're in good shape so
it's like this is the highest quality
guy you're ever going to be able to get
yeah and not it's only gonna get worse I
hear that but for me to raise a family
the way I want to raise it I want to
have money that's not for me to go spoil
my kids because I don't I think raisins
kids spoil doesn't teach them anything
but I would want them to not struggle
the way that I've struggled could you
marry a guy with money would I marry a
guy of course yeah yeah so why don't you
just do that because you could you're
pretty enough I mean thank you I could
do but I wouldn't be fulfilled and I
think in life it's all about fulfilling
your own hopes and dreams and stuff like
that so what is like this dream this
world doesn't sound real to me and this
has come I come from like my dad's a top
like one percent earner he's very very
successful and like I grew up around
successful people but yeah this this
doesn't sound real where okay because
where the mom has this successful career
and the dad also has the successful
career and they also have they also have
five kids like Something's Gotta Give
you literally can't do everything or
you're paying a nanny to raise your kid
I mean to be fair I'm not gonna lie if I
had money and I was a businesswoman and
I was busy I would have help if I could
afford it I generally would have help
and that's not me saying I can't be
bothered to look after my children it is
of course but I would be there for the
important parts though say if I had it's
not the same I do understand where
you're coming from but that would be the
sacrifice that I would take when I would
want my kids to see a world right but
that's the problem that's the modern
mindset it's about my career and me
before the family and I think that's
like what what is so broken down
nowadays is that we all care about
ourselves before the family and and to
have a family that's successful you have
to be selfless you know our grandmothers
and our great grandmothers didn't stay
with our husbands by thinking about
themselves yeah
because mothers put their child before
themselves when they have children when
they don't have children obviously you
should be thinking about that ahead of
time but I am doing by creating a career
for myself to provide for the family
that I wouldn't want so yeah you
mentioned you want to be a mother like
what are you doing to prepare to be a
mother
I eat healthy most the time
um
that was a really good question actually
that's put me on the spot well I my
daughter what are you doing so if a guy
said okay you can work for three years
he meets you today and he says okay
that's fine you're working you work for
three years and then we're gonna have
children what skills do you bring to the
table what would you say I'm a very fair
and understanding person
um I'm able to
oh gosh that's a really hard who's got
the most biggest heart oh thank you I
I'm like I said I'm a really caring
person
um I wouldn't I know what my parents did
that I would want to do different
um and yeah that's such a hard question
that put me on the spot there's a lot of
things but I just can't really think of
them
you're very ambitious as well Ashton
right right but that doesn't matter to a
guy that's ambitious and you know I I'm
ambitious but I don't give a [__] I
don't care if I cared and I love loved
you I would do anything for you like I
would be your your support your
everything right but but why because you
know it's like if you're applying to a
job you say I can do this this and this
so I understand what like when you guys
were saying earlier what you because
it's all about status for a man and
their woman like for example if there
was a group of guys and all their
girlfriends were going out on a night
out and one of the guys turned around
and said well my woman's staying at home
in his head that's a status thing for
example um for example if um your mum
was to bring his friends around and you
were to offer oh what would you guys
like to eat again that's a status thing
because your woman is taking care of you
and your friends so I I want to provide
which is where the money comes from
because I also think guys deserve to be
treated like a king it's not just the
girls should be wand and dined all the
time so that's why I want to make money
not just to be able to take my husband
out using his credit card I want to use
mine so your money is his money in the
relationship yeah okay yeah 100 do you
guys care about a girl's money
easiest
Jonathan yeah so like if she needed
something and she has my kids you know
what I'm saying then I'll be obviously
offer it to her but my money is my money
I obviously give it if you need it and
your money is my money easier that's how
it works Jonathan yeah in a marriage
yeah because you come together because
like the girl's money is my money and my
money is my money Jonathan but when she
needs something I obviously provided for
her Jonathan yeah yeah that's exactly
what I'm saying is my money but I'm not
gonna not allow you to have it because
we're married we're a partnership do you
know what I mean exactly let's say
you're a guy that needs your man needs
it but the money it's not even a
question you could have that's good
question that's very good I respect that
about you so much
thanks do you care no I don't care at
all and any woman that's ever like done
anything with me no I pay for everything
five-star hotels restaurants I'm flying
to Poland tomorrow
her and her friend is supposed to meet
up with me she said we're not rich like
that I said when have I ever had you pay
for anything you might find that I find
the offensive when a girl I find that
offensive want to go find a defensive
yeah find the offensive cause like but
isn't it rude if they don't though no no
it's not because you know who do you
think it's offensive
friends split the ball they were like oh
my friend let me split the ball with you
but the offer though would you rather a
girl that's offensive that's offensive
end of do you know what I'm saying
girls need to get used to the fact that
if I was on me the cash is on me top it
and love go is that a way to go
can I um split this with you that's
embarrassing for the moon do you know
what I'm saying the man knows he has to
pee you know what I'm saying and the
girl should know to stand back let him
handle the finances easier you can't
just say to your own man or can I offer
can I split the bill with you that's
offensive that's that's what I was
saying I'm friends with you so I offer
to split the rule if you know he was
truly your man you would just leave it
to him he'll pay you this and that you
don't think about it you know what I'm
saying you think of a guy except
splitting the Bell he doesn't like her
that much then he's a [__] bro easy as
in love okay do you know what I'm saying
yeah because like he'll go like oh yeah
let me spit the pool do you think women
that are not traditional deserve
traditional treatment no because most I
don't think traditional women exist in
2023 I think some do I think someday I
know a few versions I don't I don't
think I think even even traditional
woman can't be traditional because she's
still too influenced by the culture she
doesn't live you know rat sack in the
middle of nowhere yeah it's sick talk
Instagram right because girls follow
children
like what percent of girls have their
own cookbook of recipes from scratch
what what percent of girls like what
percent of girls like genuinely the
skills that our grandmothers had like
that they could you know my grandma um
had nine kids and she managed the
household of nine kids she could sew she
could cook she could clean and I'll just
say I can't do half of that [__] I can't
so who here knows how to sew and I do
but not very well
I've sew my clothes back together when
they have a hole in it
okay all right but but you see what I'm
saying like what percent of girls really
have those skills so like one argument
I've heard from guys is like why would I
treat her like a traditional woman when
like
please trust me the thing is you have to
train your girl like I'm not even being
rude I'm not trying to say like she's
something bad but training like yo like
even if you don't like the way she is
you can train or you can mold her you
know what I'm saying not mode
right no I I agree with you like I don't
disagree I've just heard I heard them I
think Brian talk about it on whatever
and he's like why would I split the bill
when half the time I meet these girls
and they're going to sleep with another
dude after the date so and so and so
he's saying like why why would I do that
and she has to prove to me that she's
not like that before I'm Really Gonna
treat her even if she does sleep with
guys let's say oh for you yeah you don't
know that she's a scared yet you still
payable that's your instinct as a man
even if she's a step over 100 guys you
still pay the bill you look like oh
split the bill you can have the bill
shut up just pay the bill get on with
[Music]
I agree with him because I think when
you go on a date you should you should
be dating with intent for first off
right you should be asking questions
that are meaningful and purposeful and
beneficial to your long-term commitment
right so if you realize that that girl
is not a modern mentality woman
he said as a man
pay the bill you enjoy your night yeah
I'm out why am I gonna waste my time
with a girl that I know is not going to
give me what I need unless you want to
have fun with her for like one or two
times if that's what you want to do
go to the house and then pay the drinks
and then have sex with her and then send
her home have sex with her again if
that's the lane you want to take but I
mean I mean if you're not if you're
looking for more than just fun right you
meet a girl you realize she's not really
that modern mental she's she's a modern
mentality woman she's not like more
Traditional Values why am I gonna waste
my time I don't got no issue with you
I'm just gonna pay the bill you and have
a drink his his thing is like he just
doesn't want to waste his money on
someone that is modern or like a modern
mental because he's like I mean that's
my mistreat right because she's most
likely talking to like 10 dudes sleeping
with another dude you know I'm not I'm
not saying you do where you don't I was
just curious what you think of that it's
just the cost of taking risk right yeah
I'm saying because you don't really know
until you meet the person so if I
invited her out I mean I gotta take that
L right you know a couple you guys go on
another date with a guy if he didn't pay
the bill
yeah
I've been on dates well I've paid for
for the other day yeah and it hasn't
bothered me though never
doesn't get to me I'm not that kind of
person yeah
um yeah yeah no it doesn't work but it
wasn't a one-time thing
I never saw him again there you go but
it wasn't it wasn't just because it
wasn't because of that I just didn't
really like him like that but only in a
relationship I will
you only sleep with a guy in a
relationship
yeah I'm talking about paying yeah what
about
um what about you if you had to go back
would you stay a virgin until you're
married
no
you'll never change no no it's just it's
crazy you know it caused you trauma like
you said that and you said you see how
it's damaging like why wouldn't you
because to me if I like if I know if I
know a relationship like you know
because people are like oh I wouldn't
change anything and I think it I would
absolutely maybe then yeah yeah you know
it didn't work yeah I see where you're
coming from but I don't know I just
don't like being bored I feel like I'd
have too much Temptation I'm not patient
I'm not a patient person so I feel like
have you ever been in love probably
alone
and that you're gonna say loyal to him
for the rest of your life you have to
find a guy that you proper love yeah
maybe I just haven't had them emotions
what do you think lovers
I think love is I believe in our heart
life yeah what do you think it is more
than just a feeling I think it's
different for boys and girls I can't
learn yeah I think so too so for girls
it's a feeling obviously it's not a lot
it's not a physical thing is it so when
a girl she only thinks about him she
sees the future of him only that's like
things in her head I can't replace this
guy so I can't get anything better than
him I'm gonna stick with him he's the
love of my life I respect him
and for the man like that's a beautiful
thing for a woman yeah like and but the
guys to be higher valued you know what
I'm saying a girl can't just be head
over heels in love with a guy that's not
how about you I can't be a homeless guy
that speaks words like you saying I have
problems on that she went full head over
there was a love of him that's in fairy
tales that's to be high value for the
value to matter to the love to matter I
think that's what I go through like I
feel like it's just a lust all the time
yeah it's just the feeling you know you
know you know what I did the other day
you can be in love more than once
[Music]
but I can speak for women on behalf like
how come how come like we have exes
right
um
you clearly was in love with them and
then you move like that didn't work out
and now you're in love with someone else
so it's just a feeling so you can have
it with anything do you feel like the
older you get you can't fall in love as
hard
because I I think there's nothing like
your first love yeah like I think the
first guy that you're really in love
with like you don't ever fall in love
that hard I think that's actually true
for men and for women like I I just
think there's nothing like your first
love and so it's like why would I not
want to field out with my husband
because now it's like the the love you
experience with your husband isn't the
same level of deep as the one you
experienced before I don't you know what
I don't think I've ever been in I feel
like in the moment I feel like I'm in
love but then even with my first going
back it was definitely just a lost thing
yeah definitely just a love story
you like the feeling of the affection
and you like the feeling of being
comforted someone being there just kind
of like a friend not them obviously
being a friend but like someone being
there like your mom you know just the
feeling of it and if you don't have that
you hold on to it more and when
especially with like damaged people if
people have gone and and came back gone
and came back and you get attachment
issues so when you when you do find that
person that actually wants to be there
and loves you the way that yeah and then
they go it do you think that's love but
like sometimes well they wouldn't have
gone if it's like yeah yeah they'll
always be in your life but I disagree
with that I think that people that love
you can leave if you treat them poorly
oh yeah yeah yeah and I think a lot of
times with women we always put ourselves
as like the victim in relationships when
a lot of times people took him for
granted or be treating him poorly yeah
so he laughed and maybe he loved you but
he laughed because he just got sick of
the I think we're sold the dream like
we're told you have this Prince Charming
that's waiting and you're just perfect
enough to do nothing like even you when
I ask you like what skills are you
working on to be a wife yeah or to be a
mother you were like uh and I've thought
of something
no but but it's like if you were really
working on it all the time it would be
the top of your head which is I don't
think you're abnormal but it's like
we're not told we have to work for the
men we want yeah I think definitely in
in this day and age in this Society
obviously women are very much more
encouraged to go and chase their dreams
so I think at the moment I mean I am in
my selfish my selfish era of thinking
about what I want for my future but in
two years time when I've achieved most
of those things my perspective again
will be different I mean I can cook I
can clean I can I can take care of
myself first and foremost which means I
can take care of someone else so I'm
working on myself to be a better person
for my future husband if that makes
sense how many meals did you cook this
week
so awesome uh if you asked me two weeks
ago it would have been better but I've
had quite a few days I'm not gonna lie
to you no it's okay I just think
sometimes like as girls we think that we
do things more than we do and I just
noticed like I'll ask girls like they'll
say they can cook but they haven't
cooked in a month or two months to be
fun no I do I every week I will have a
cooked home cooked meal
um but more than most to be honest you
see that study that came out that went
or not went like the increase in
takeaway like Americans don't it's like
they don't eat out as much but it's
mostly like microwave meals because it's
easy it's convenient it's inconvenient
like I don't have like a normal nine to
five schedule lifestyle I'll be like
tonight I'm gonna be home late so I
won't want to cook anything yeah I'll
just I'll grab something quick from my
phone that I can do because the food's
so accessible it makes sense but this is
why we don't have as many traditional
women nowadays yeah because you have to
do something I would say you have to do
something pretty much every day to get
really good at it you know you have to
work out every day to be good at working
out you have to cook every day to be
good at cooking yeah but does cooking
make you a good wife like is this are we
talking about like kids Gotta Eat don't
they yeah yeah yeah yeah but like like
let's just say like
whole meals like
is is that just something you have to do
I can't explain this in a way I mean it
doesn't make it doesn't make you yeah
like what makes a good wife
um I think a wife that's loyal um I
think it's good if you have traditional
skills like you know how to keep a
household you know how like if you want
five kids and you say I know how to feed
a family yeah I've done it these times
you know what you know
um I think good with kids loving caring
uh what else would you add what makes a
good wife
I've obviously being a virgin makes a
good birth
oh yeah I forgot obviously my wife has
to be a virgin before I met her
otherwise it went wrong because I can't
have the thought in my head but she
sucked up obviously obviously Mama
wasn't them
I don't know
he was like I couldn't get my finger my
point of course in it because of my man
anyway I was trying to say is like like
when you would you wait till marriage
with a girl
yeah like you can't sleep with her until
you're married no her but other girls
yes but her no I would wait of course
I'll do it because I respect her
decisions you know what I'm saying okay
but obviously I'll speed up sleeping
over girls it's not a big deal I'll
still love my girl get married to her
easiest you know what I'm saying it's
not that it's not complicated you're
sleeping with other girls
why would she not where did she not love
me
yeah but that's why it would hurt her
because she doesn't love you okay but
some some things in life her if I'm not
gonna have sex with you for how many
years I'm obviously yeah but you'd find
it hard though Birkin when the man at
the end of the day you've got needs have
sex with all the girls and her yeah
I'll respect her decision to wait
because I respect her if she wants to
wait or if she wants to give it to me I
still respect it because I want to look
after her I'm going to get married to
her do you know what I'm saying so if
she's a virgin and I take a Virginia
East good if she's a virgin and I take
it and I don't take her virginity it's
all marriage then I'll take it then it's
still good you know what I'm saying but
what so I think I think Virginia is very
important guys if you're listening get
married to a virgin bro on camera
version of Jonathan what are you gonna
tell you what are you doing I tweet
about this what are you gonna do with
the kids we're gonna tell your kids oh
your mom sucked another dick before
getting married to me what kind of
[__] is that why would you say that
though
I think if men had that standard women
would be better I think it's great that
you have that standard exactly like
genuinely and this is and I'm not a
virgin but I could tell you like if men
had that standard and you knew that if
you had sex with someone else you
probably wouldn't get married every girl
would wait but everyone wants to get
married and the bad thing is the bad
thing is like every time yeah after you
lose a virginity every time you have sex
with another guy you're going to want to
do more of other guys and more and more
it's just like Spiral to homeless
Jonathan yeah so it's good to like wait
till marriage to find the guy that you
love and get married to him like have a
nice family with him do you know what
I'm saying what do you think what do you
think of Born Again virgins would you
say born again yeah like a girl that has
had sex and then makes him wait later
I agree
no no girls do that they'll like go to
church and then like decide they're
gonna wait yeah you can't just repent
for that you stupid
you go the guy ever wants a virgin I
think any guy that signs up for that is
naive and probably how can you be born
again you got you were a virgin once and
you could never be virgin again how can
you be born maybe I should do it makes
no sense
can I do that for a YouTube video that'd
be so funny
tell them your body count and that's it
but I've decided I've changed
we can say that I just want to see how
that would go but we get ripped faces
but I have already so yeah whatever How
can there be a lot of people that
respect you though
because a lot of girls might like hide
it and don't actually feel insecure
about it it was even like when I was on
next on the beach I got disrespected a
lot when I was on that
um and both guys guys I was on there
with they just didn't respect me at all
uh why like whatever because of my
reputation did you tell them that your
body count was no but it seems like more
than one of them no only ever won but I
think it's because they knew my history
so it was like what's the point
respecting her because of what she's
done in the past and men that she slept
with and how many so it's like it always
reflects on me whatever I do but I was
honest about it and I was like so what's
the point yeah like what do you know
what's mad though you're one of the
nicest girls that I've ever met and you
know what I mean and it just people
should look beyond beyond that yeah
because you are generally the most
kindest genuine sweetheart but they're
not judging numbers but but it's like
it's like if you're gonna apply for a
job and the job is being loyal and she
has no history of it how can he because
you kind of have to look at like you
know the same way you would look is she
good with kids like how much time does
she spend with children like you would
take that into account it's not to say
you're not a good person like you're
super sweet but it's different when
you're applying for a job like I think a
wife is a job yeah I know 100 I think
yeah but it's it's like for example it's
like all these people that are super
educated and go to like the best schools
but that doesn't make them a better
person or better able for that job
yeah yeah it does do you reckon yeah I
mean I think not all the time not 100
but I would say would you rather have a
doctor operating night on you I think
that works so you would rather have a
doctor operating on you that went to the
best schools than the worst schools
right oh 100 I think it's different for
different things like for example I'd be
a great lawyer like I'd be so good but
I'm definitely happy as well but I'm not
educated in that aspect I'm like I'm
just not educated so how would they know
you would be a good lawyer if you have
no work experience because I think when
someone is put in a certain room and
they are able to deliver a certain job
and they're still good at it then it
doesn't matter whether you've got this
person's got more qualifications or or
not do you know what I'm trying to say
no again
um no I genuinely think you have to have
the skills to be good at a job but
skills isn't education though
and with the like being a wife like I
think having the skills to be a wife
with his Purity which is typically
Purity youth you know good with kids can
cook manage a household like like
there's actual skills that are good to
have yeah I'm not saying every guy cares
about every one of them femininity like
and I want to go because I have body
count she loses that Purity she loses
you know soon
so she becomes more like not damaged but
more experienced you know I'm saying
less pure you know what I'm saying
as well yeah let's say let's say girls
that are like 17 18 19 20 that young yes
there are virgins they're all like love
dogs more love and like kids movies you
know what I'm saying because they're
pure but once they go through that
trauma that damagedness you know what
I'm saying I've been damaged though and
I'm great with kids
I'm fantastic kids love me really yeah
yeah that shouldn't affect how you yeah
but it but it affects how you are in a
relationship because you bring that
damage into future relationship I think
the damage that you've got is your
responsibility to to go away inhale from
it I I agree with you but what's better
a girl that's not damaged or a girl that
is
I I understand why I do understand what
you're saying but say if you got married
and then a guy damaged you within that
marriage you even though you've only
slept with that person you would still
be damaged
right but they're probably there are
problems not other people's problems and
the issue is like you're bringing other
people's problems into your relationship
which is then why you would need to go
away and work on yourself no which is
why you should have less Partners before
you get married which is why we should
try to remain as pure as possible before
we get married like why would you want
more experience before getting married
what value does that bring to a husband
I've just I've just thought um you know
like that time when you're little or you
have to kiss a lot of frogs before you
get your your prince so that's a bad
saying I think that's experience that's
what we've grown up on though so that's
when I'm saying yes as girls we I I
personally wasn't told by anyone oh if
you sleep with a lot of people your
value as a woman's gonna go down if if I
was told that you think you think that
our father figure has an important role
in that to be fair yeah actually maybe
but then my my mom didn't say that
either well we know the sun some level
because the first thing you do and you
don't like a girl is you call her a
[__] maybe not you personally but you
know women do that so I think we know on
some level that Purity is important to
me I don't think when you're 16 17
though I don't think you think about
that at all at all did you guys have no
guidance from your parents no my mom
didn't talk about sex with me at all not
even did you lose your dad in your life
yeah yeah both parents and they never
they never spoke to you about sex ever
never maybe they should I I do think
they should have definitely because I'm
not saying that um I would go back and
change things because I I do feel like
even through breakups and bad breakups
you out from the other side and the end
of the tunnel you become a better person
anyway because you've I feel like I
think I think you become a worse person
as a human expect being a human on the
planet having a human experience they
say say that to have a full experience
as a human you have to go through ups
and downs that's not just some
relationships that's experiences in
general yeah so you should go through
them with your husband
why sure
that I would rather go through I'm not
on about just relationships but as an
experience I would rather go through
that on my own so then when I'm with my
husband I've already learned all of that
yeah no no
but why would you not want to know it
but listen
as an individual on the planet as an
individual going for your own life
surely you would want to know everything
about yourself everything that triggers
you everything that you know you've
learned from and all of that and then
have a husband that you can build even
more you're not going to go wrong
because why would you want to be in a
marriage not knowing yourself yeah 100
like why would you why would you want to
do that yeah but from the dawn of time
like from the ancient times girls I've
gotten married at a young age I don't
agree with that they don't need that
they didn't get married at first girls
got married at 16 17 18. that was just
something that just happened from from
the whole of like from ages ago it's a
new thing to get married but maybe
sometimes they didn't actually have a
choice yeah but it's not that but it was
like it was a tradition
to get married
because we look at what works and like
let's let's look at the outcomes are
women happier waiting to get married
right the average age of first marriage
is 31 100 years ago it was around 20 21
something like that and women are more
on antidepressants we're more depressed
than ever we're on what Tinder where
average body count is like what eight
ten and like I I genuinely think it's
probably higher than that if we're being
honest you know
um if we're not happy women are not
happy waiting to get married and then
getting married I think happiness is a
choice though I think I do think
happiness is a choice but I do think we
can look at outcomes yeah I I completely
understand where you're coming from but
again I think it's so important to take
the time away and focus on yourself
what do you think the difference between
happiness for a woman is and happiness
for a man is
what do you think freedom
what female break it down let's see
what's the difference between the
happiness for a man and the happiness
for a woman what's the difference
I think when you're both happy I think
that's when you can be completely happy
yeah
for a woman yeah what makes a woman
happy like happy like Papa happy and
fulfilled and what makes a man happy and
fulfilled I think it's personal
preference yeah I think it's different
everyone is different but to generalize
it I think for a man it's having a woman
who
this is gonna sound so politically wrong
but I know that guys can cheat and be
and still love someone and and then if
they were to then go back to that woman
and that woman takes them back it would
give him status because look how much my
woman loves me
tell anyone that's a [__] boy why would
he tell anyone what you mean but he
doesn't have to that's not stupid I
think she's saying a support process
that's not status like boasting about uh
his girl taking them back to Sunday but
some guys do do that I've heard I've
seen a podcast with them having this
whole conversation I'm not saying just
specifically
what makes a woman happy
I think being cared for provided for
looked after disrespected recognized
okay that's that's very good well also
you don't need need a man yes
the only reason like we have a we have a
society where women are like delusional
enough to think that we can't live
without men no offense uh because like
what what do you do when your car breaks
down you go to a man what do you do who
built this building a man
no not really all the industries that
run Society are primarily I mean it's
not that they can't we don't and we
won't we refuse to do hard jobs all the
hardest jobs
no not really if even if you look at
them and I've talked to like I do
interviews sometimes with people in
these industries typically the women are
the ones waving the flags on the
construction sites or they're like in
the middle management like most women
are out there building and if they're
doing it come on they're bad at it let's
just call Spade Spade like you're not
you're not just good at like doing
manual labor as a man you can't be we're
not as strong as them and so yeah we're
not as strong as men if there's if
there's a blackout tomorrow right if
there's a blackout tomorrow you would
run to a guy because you need a guy to
protect you they did a study right or
not a study a TV show where um they put
men and women on an island and said
survive go the women had to be rescued
in two days and in like five days the
men were filtering water hunting food
like they had a whole system that's just
how would life differently built like
right but that's what I'm saying like
women like we're in a society where we
have like propped up women to think that
we can live without men when everything
we do depends on men like then they need
us women to be here no not really
because like okay let's let's say
reproduction's equal right we can't say
because we need we need their sperm they
need our so we can't we can't take more
credit for reproduction like that's
equal but when it comes to a baby though
whereas a woman can't okay but what okay
if they build artificial wombs tomorrow
then what
there's no laws stopping us from doing
any of these industries if you want you
can go be a plumber you could go be a
mechanic but I'm sure none of you want
to and I sure as hell don't right you
don't want to I don't want to either and
and it's interesting because I talked to
this like historian the other day and he
said there have just been such
ramifications from women entering the
workforce in the 20s
because like that's like the that as
soon as women entered the workforce in
the 20s that's when the number of
children went down and that's when like
um that's when you couldn't survive on
two incomes so there's been a lot of
ramification I'm not saying good or bad
but from women entering the workforce
but they say they don't need men right
but hypothetically
you see how big that muscle is right
there the security guard for the show
right if he was to try to violate you
they say me and you were together
Courtney
and we were walking down the street hey
if he was trying to violate you he would
have to kill me to get you to
you don't see value in that because
because when he means it enough because
what I'm saying the point that you guys
are we've conquered the world to the
point where you guys are so protected to
the point that you guys don't even see
valuable and simple security you guys
are entitled to security
you understand that I don't have to
protect you if if someone as big as him
was to try to violate you he would have
to kill me I don't have to do that for
you
to the point to say that you don't need
men you do need Men You're so secure
because the fact that we've conquered
the world I think we've gave you that
security but you're not entitled to it
you're not entitled to it all right so
if we're walking together and he says
something what are you gonna do yeah but
it wasn't aimed I'm not saying that
though no but she's talking about
needing men you do need men yeah because
you're not entitled security you could
walk down the street right now and
somebody attack you right but if you had
a man with you that man would be willing
to die for you then and they're on the
spot yeah you and me I I'm a I'm a dive
you gotta kill me
yeah yeah
yeah so you mean men don't let this
society that we've conquered and built
is so secure for you forget that because
a man could see a a pervert a pedophile
whatever because see you walk in the
show she's pretty she's got a skirt on
let me find an opportunity he's going to
follow bro why is that so special bro is
that not a normal that's normal forgot
to protect the girl why are you Dylan on
it because they don't value them
not you particularly but we're talking
about modern women not valuing men and
one the thing that men one of the men
that one of the things that men brings
to the table more than anything is
protection okay bro that's not important
it's new movies
out there that won't do nothing there
are men out there there are men out
there that when men do something to
their women they will not do anything
they are cowards and they want to do
anything do not tell me that it's not
valuable for a man to stand for women
because 99
it's not normal it's not rich people
it's not cool
yes you would you predict oh yes you
would yes you would yes you would I
would anyone else would only a little
geek whatever and there's a lot of
cowards out there that's what I'm saying
that's what I'm saying
it would be surprising exactly I think
it's normal for a guy
I've seen plenty of dudes lay down and
do nothing where you from America [__]
America I don't care about my computer
you say we just said whatever cool and
that's cool I've not seen a guy that's
stepped down from like protecting his yo
I've seen that this is that 13 times
I've seen it I've not seen it like who's
gonna run who's obviously gonna run away
from his girl I've seen it I've seen
dudes like grab a girl's ass and the
dude really does nothing because exactly
I've seen that's right
it's common I'm kind of torn I've seen
both you know what I mean
yeah you're saying that it happens but
it's not it's not common bro but it
happens
exactly but it's not about people
because everyone does it it's normal bro
it's normal for God to protect the woman
easier but he doesn't have to do it the
point is the value they have to see
value in it of course they have to do it
bro it's normal no but it's if you okay
it's like if you're single right there's
some value in having a boyfriend and
that can protect you so if someone
breaks into your apartment at night and
he's there he can protect you you know
that's what I think I think it might be
normal but that's what he's trying to
say that women don't value that you
know like women don't I'm saying that
it's not about I'm not I'm not saying
that it's not normal and that a man
shouldn't do it a man being a man should
do it what I'm saying is that generally
modern women today don't value the
simple thing of a protection which is
the most valuable thing a man can do
it's not the most valuable thing it is
the most valuable thing to lay your life
on a life for a woman is the most
valuable thing you can do it's the most
valuable thing to do if I love a woman I
will die for there on the spot this is
my life this is all I have because that
is
average you might be saying it's normal
on average but you'd be surprised about
how many men don't do it that's who's
yeah he's he's agreeing with you
to you it is normal to me it is normal a
guy should do that but you'd be
surprised about how many men and that's
his problem that's his point arguing the
fact that bro we're on the same level
but it's like just a little bit I'm
saying
it's so valuable it's so valuable it's
normal it's not valuable it's normal no
it is value
I said I don't know where you're from
bro but where I'm from a lot of [__]
happens
bro I've seen a lot of [__] happen lay
down like [__] don't really happen and
dudes do nothing
bro like really it'll happen America is
very different from the UK and I I
personally I haven't been there but even
just on TV you can see how Savage
but just in general though just you can
see
fiery you seen it I've done I've done
stood up for my dudes a girlfriend when
he wouldn't stand up for us bro
it's not normal
security No it should be normal and a
man should do that what I'm saying is
that there are men out there that will
not do that and what I'm saying is that
most men women don't that most modern
women don't value the Simplicity of
security you're not interested they're
not gonna expect it it's normal for them
that's his point so you're just not
understanding it's like he just wants to
argue no I don't think so I think you
guys are just misunderstanding each
other like yeah I think that's
just like you know women don't value it
and it's like like his point is that
women don't respect average men nowaday
even when they're average women
like I think I think that's I think let
me tell you something I think protecting
a girl is normal average standards it's
just normal you can't it's not something
that you value it's normal average yeah
I also think a man doesn't value a woman
enough
huh
do you not hear what I said what'd you
say I said I don't think a man values a
woman enough why is that what do you
think that
it's just in general it's just the
society we live in yeah
okay do you think a man
you think a man would rub a value a girl
that's a virgin or a girl
as a person
they're not value women because women
don't bring anything to the table
we bring we're fat yeah but okay a dog
carries like why do we act like this is
so special and crazy and the crazy
things and well yeah but and women don't
go through the process because half of
us aren't going to have kids and even if
we you know what's special my grandma
I've on both sides one carried nine kids
and one carried 13. at modern women
won't even carry three and and they wait
too long so you know the average age of
first marriage is 31. how many kids can
you carry at 31. so why would they value
that when we don't bring anything
nowadays
what what percent of women are cooking
on a regular basis what percent of women
why can't the men do that because men
because men and women are different and
most men out earn women so if we're
going to talk about like a guy that's a
provider like most men only four percent
of relationships the woman out earns the
man so most men still out earn us but we
don't we don't bring anything we're not
we're not we're not virgins anymore what
percent of women are virgins on our
wedding day and you can't just be you
can't just be a Who
like let's say it goes a hoya and then
expect the man like disrespect the man
saying why can't you do it or why is it
not the same with us just shush and the
other thing is like if you don't if if
women feel like men don't value them
it's probably because they don't bring
anything to be valued it's like okay if
a man is rejected by every single girl
right if he goes up to 100 women and he
and and he's rejected by all of them
wouldn't you think well there's probably
something wrong with dude 100 that's a
lot of women to reject him but if a
woman sleeps with guy after guy after
guy and all of them cheat on her and
none of them want to be in a
relationship with her and none of them
are committed to her none of them value
her maybe something's wrong with her
maybe there's something she doesn't
bring but it's like it never women we're
so narcissistic that we never think
maybe it's us it's always them it's like
the men don't value us but maybe you
don't bring anything to Value you know
we had um we had a woman come here and
she taught an episode of wife school and
I'm telling you like she was she was oh
she was a bit bigger right but she was
so feminine so kind so caring there was
not a man in the room that didn't
respect her and value her and that just
would never happen to her because she
brought something to the table but it's
like as women we keep bringing nothing
to the table then wondering why guys
don't respect us
yeah I do hear what you're saying but I
think as well
I suppose you know like toxic
relationships the whole toxic situation
is so heightened on the internet oh
everyone's toxic and I think
because of social media it's brought
this negative
atmosphere around relationships in a
sense because if you didn't have social
media you wouldn't be able to see what
other people are doing and how they are
who's on social media more men or women
oh I don't know you know I think it's
it's women so if like if you say like
Society social media influences it's
influencing the women and then we what
we go into relationships and expect what
toxicity I mean I personally don't I
don't want a toxic relationship you
might be an exception but we're talking
about the rule like we're talking about
common problems and like we even said
you know like women want the roller
coaster we want the ups and downs in our
relationships and then you know again we
we ask why do the men not value US do
you guys think the phrase is true men
will do anything for sex
to an extent yeah yes yeah so if we
treat if they treat us a certain way
isn't that our own fault because they'll
do anything for sex so if we're sleeping
with the ones that act bad
and that's our own fault if they treat
us like that that they'll act good
before you sleep with them and then
they'll start yeah that's what normally
happens so you've already kind of gained
a little bit of attack you know I I
disagree with this because I've had
friends in toxic relationships and all
of the friends will tell them yeah
that's a toxic man the parents will tell
them you know not a good one like like
let's just let's just call spade a spade
if you ask your dad about him he
probably wouldn't like him or your
brothers are like men you respect in
your life like I think it's just a
cop-out that women say oh he's changed
all the time and if if that's true then
why don't you wait longer before
sleeping with men if they change
um if we waited to be married to have
sex with someone then we'd all be
married
yeah true so it's kind of like if the
men are acting so and people always say
I get on the women but it's like what
comes first nowadays sex or
relationships in general sex
sex right you agree sex who's in control
of sex the woman so so who's in control
in relationships
the woman so really how is a woman in
control sex because men are always
trying to get like men control access to
relationships women control access to
sex but sex comes before relationships
right it's because we always give
consent yeah like women has the last say
and if if the sex happens or not yeah
like they're gonna screw anything you
know what I mean like you come naked in
front of it like come on
do you think guys are that picky with
who they sleep with women are right so
we're in control of sex so it's like if
relationships are in the [__] whose
fault is that um
when we were the ones that pick right
Savage
I I agree with what you're saying 100
but I just think it's difficult
because guys don't give you the whole
experience of themselves they give you a
perception or they show you a little
teaser they'll give you a percentage
they show you what they want to show you
so then wait to sleep with them but then
if I mean
I don't sleep with someone right away
anyway but if I've gained a level of
comfortability with you because of what
you've shown me and who you are as a
person and then I sleep with you and
then after you change then you clearly
would just do in that 40 seconds right
but it's probably because you didn't
offer anything other than sex guys don't
get bored with women that offer things
other than sex
majority of them do get bored I don't
even care about sexual
right it's all you think of yeah
have you ever asked a guy what his
favorite meal is and learn to cook it
from scratch and like did it on a
consistent basis like dropped it off
maybe every other day
would that be valuable to you guys yes a
girl that drops off like a home-cooked
meal or like comes would that be
valuable yes
yeah that's my only point right but I'm
asking like nobody nobody's done that
right I mean I mean I was talking to a
guy quite recently and every time he'd
come around I would ask him well what do
you want and I kind of I knew what he
liked so I'd I'd make it for him do you
know what I mean let's like bring
something to the table that's something
but I'm not saying yeah we don't need to
bring everything to the table but like
what does he like he said he mentioned
today but for him for him to be talking
to you he has to bring something to the
table because you you guys are all
pretty girls you are not dealing with no
guy that's completely broke you're not
dealing with no guy that's super ugly
like in order for him to even get in the
door you have to bring something the
difference is women don't have to bring
anything
you just have to be be pretty
to get in the door
what's the man bringing to the table uh
again okay do you want a guy that's
smarter than you
typically yes do you want a guy that's
taller than you no deaf I got a lot
short guys
okay so do you want to know that's
stronger than you yeah do you want a guy
that makes more money than you
ideally if you could pick
yeah yeah right so be so off the bat he
has to bring something to the table Yeah
to get in the door
but you don't and that's the point like
we get in the door and we think we're
bringing something to the table but
we're not
we're just being pretty in there is is
that though with them having money or
whatever right but that's probably why
like you haven't been in successful
relationships you know that might be the
problem well I just think everything
should be equal in life why should I
feel like I have to bring it but okay
but it's not fair to the men that you
can get in the door because you're
pretty
yeah yeah
life isn't fair like women we get
privileged all the time even just
getting on the show right the women just
you guys just have to be pretty
and yeah yeah where it's funny where the
men have to have a following or they
have to have like done something I agree
but that's that's not like the topic
we're talking about talk about like no
no but it's but it's the same but guys
it's the same Dynamic that's what I'm
I'm pointing out yeah because even like
this podcast the same thing with dating
like men have to have a certain amount
of requirement women only swipe right on
dating apps five percent of the time
when men swipe right 50. so 50 of women
are getting in the door we're only five
maybe 15 percent of men are getting in
the door but majority of the swipes is
them wanting a [__]
um
but the point is what is what does
relationships start with
sex
now not necessarily not always but now
generally I personally wouldn't like I
have
but not now but this is sort of the same
problem as earlier we're the LA like the
guy that you actually that you want to
be with now you're making him wait were
the last whatever money got to hit it
for free like it's like offensive to
guys it's the same thing with with dates
right yeah like when I gave you guys the
date example where maybe he took you to
Taco Bell and he took her on this
five-star restaurant that's offensive
right that's how guys see it
it's just a mad world that we live in
now I think and there's just so much
like women generally don't think about
the men that's that's the point here you
guys think about yourself
I do yeah but my girlfriend's about me
she cares about me I love her Jonathan
but that's probably a reflect of how you
treat her though if you treated her like
[__] let's say I was a broke boy weasel
peasant yeah I wouldn't have this kind
of love that I have learned you
understand I've done stuff to in order
to put myself up there yeah Cash Wise
respect guys like covers my words
everything was yeah that reflects on her
love towards me you know
it has a part to play in it it's not
everything I think it's a lot I think
it's a lot of like the reason that the
Love's so strong you know what I'm
saying
let's say I walk them with no it's not
that it's not that it's not that it's
always someone better it's not that I
have money it's cause I'm respected it's
what money brings Jonathan the freedom
everybody's respect for you the
spontaneity it brings that you can go
here at this time at 3 P.M let's go to
the park let's go to the let's go by the
lake you know what I'm saying I think I
can't do that or it's a specific time to
like nine to five see me off the five
baby as always can't do anything special
can't go on holiday I'll take my girl on
holidays you know what I'm saying it's
I personally think
but the happiest relationships end up
being where the woman is dependent on
her man Jonathan and that's when it
happens not when it goes in another job
working under some next guys telling
what to do that's not the way to go
because I can't personally have my goal
listening to orders for my next [__]
mom what she had her own business though
what if she was a businesswoman and was
the CEO of her own company a problem but
I'll take over what's my business how is
that your business that's my business
you have to look at it after the kids
that's my business yeah honestly I'm
just telling you if something like for a
26 year old like you know I've built
this whole thing myself congratulations
thank you it's amazing thank you but but
the thing is like men don't care
they don't care enough anything for
successful guys it's it's harder because
I don't have as much free time as the
next girl like it's not and what he's
talking about like taking you know how
much stress comes with a business that
sounds so nice like to have a guy take
it like you'd have to try really trust
him and I'm like that sounds so nice to
have a guy taking over because it's like
having a business does not make you a
better partner at all like if anything
it makes you worse you're stressed out
yeah it's a lazy girl
I mean you know but men just don't care
as much about that like they don't want
a girl that sits around but that's not
like why don't you transfer that
productivity to being a housewife or a
mother yeah you can do that for a
business you can do that for your family
because then the business gets the best
of you
that's selfish because your family
should get the best of you
yeah so now you're busy your business
gets all your creativity your business
like you're or the business that you
work like let's be honest because most
women don't have right but you your the
goal is to be with a guy that makes more
than you right it's not my goal yeah I
mean let's just okay if you had got like
let's just call spade a spade got a guy
B one guy makes 100K one guy makes 30.
they're the same guy you're gonna pick
the 100k yeah everyone would like I'm
not I'm not sure unless it was right now
then I probably wouldn't because I would
rather build with someone than have
someone right but the expectation is
that he gets to a point that he can pay
of course of course right because you
want to have kids right yeah yeah five
kids like what is that gonna cost oh a
thousands right so he's gotta he's gotta
make a good amount of money of course
and and the point is no matter how good
your business is when you have kids you
have to put it aside or your kids are
going to be influenced by someone else
well that's you know when I said earlier
how about I think if you want to be a
businesswoman and you want to be a
mother you'd have to establish that
business before you had kids because if
he was a CEO you could hand that down to
someone else you could still be a part
of the business but you wouldn't be
there full time because your business is
established you can work from home you
can have other people doing things for
you why'd you need it why'd you need the
business because that's because I know
that I can offer that I know that I've
had businesses before what should it
goes be honest here from a childhood
what did you dream of having I dreamed
very nice house having kids having a
nice husband yeah and when you grow up
you saw them
so what was the dream type of business
my dream was to be to follow my
grandparents footsteps and be on the
West End I never ever once thought oh
husband husband
yeah
no my dreams changed now what is the
West End
Broadways
yeah yeah I grew up on cool so who do
you think's up here yeah a girl that is
stressing about a business running the
employees you might not be stressing
about it
you you can't there there is no way
you're making money and you're not
stressed about it I promise to God any
girl that says otherwise is capping and
the thing is our hormones are different
so we don't deal with stress the same
way that men deal with stress and that's
like especially since I've gotten into
management I I understand why women are
bad at it to be on women are horrible in
management no because because seriously
like we are not meant to like I talked
to a doctor
um I interviewed him like I don't know a
week or two ago and he was telling me
like we do not process stress the same
way that men do like we're not built
foreign and we're more agreeable so you
have to go against how like because when
you're managing someone you have to be
on them to make sure they're doing their
job and that that causes us stress
because women are more agreeable than
men so a lot of times they sell you this
oh like you can just run a business and
not be stressed there's no way I think
if it's successful unless you're unless
it's unsuccessful if you're not making
money you very well you you might not be
stressed but sorry go ahead I was just
saying I think
when you have a business and you're
stressed it's not a bad stress because
you know that you're going to get yes it
is you've got kids to look afterwards
yes yes you've got a family you haven't
got time to look after a business and
stress over that look half the employees
you have kids if a husband never
householder I think [__] a business
and so on one level you're right it's
not the same type of work like when I
used to work in sales and I was horrible
correct and so when there is a type of
like love you get from doing something
you're interested but I'm telling you if
you if you become successful and you get
to the point where you're making good
money it comes with a lot of problems
everything good worth having comes with
some sort of issue because it wouldn't
be worth having and that's the thing
it's a trade-off yeah and the issue is
like as a woman if you make more money
it is tougher for you in dating it is
not an asset to men and men do not care
about it yeah it is not it's not a bonus
like especially to the men that we want
it is nothing to them yeah but I'm not
doing it for a man I'm doing it for me
right but that's my life that's the
original problem though is as women we
never think about like what the men want
yeah I'm sure but I'm sure there's men
out that that would want a woman to have
a business not necessarily a business
but have a career you're right the broke
ones
I have guy friends that are doing
extremely well for themselves and they
want the best for me in the sense that
it's more attractive for them to have
someone who's not a housewife but then
there's other guys that would probably
want a housewife so again it comes down
to your environment really you've grown
up the reason I mean some guys like they
want girls with money to offset the risk
of Merit but it's not really an
attraction thing like men men are never
going to look at Oprah and say oh she's
so hot because she's Rich yeah but but
women will look at say Trump like how
many hot girls have slept with Trump
that man is not like let's just he's not
attractive right because he has power
status money and so we're just not
attracted to the same things
yeah I get what you're saying but I
don't think I don't really agree to be
honest
you think men are lined up to to sleep
with Oprah no no not that so I just like
I don't know it's just the whole power
thing like I think yeah I don't think
women want to sleep with Kings
presidents yeah I mean I agree with that
so women do love power you don't think
women want to to sleep with the CEO of
companies it takes it but that's a
specific
that word type of woman though because I
wouldn't I would one girl might look at
a man with tons of money and think oh my
gosh yes and that that's who I want I'm
gonna chase him but I would look at him
and be like congratulations but that
doesn't impress me girls can we
admissions
cool you girls would rather have someone
that's important to not important
easiest yes or no yeah of course yeah
that's it easier but being important
doesn't mean money though what does it
mean then who you are as an individual
who you are cool let's say a homeless
guy who is yeah so you've ever sleep
with a homeless guy
I see what you're saying but
like men prefer women that live with
their parents exactly so in a way that's
it no I'm saying I mean I don't think
they want Comics come on for girls
homeless on the street she had to have
made some bad Life Choices together it
is so hard to be homeless you how many
women's shelters there are like you have
no relatives that'll take you in no
ex-boyfriend was gonna be something yeah
yeah but men like genuine I've heard men
talk about like they prefer women that
live with their parents really they're
not show somebody time there yeah
because think about it you're not doing
as much Madness if you're you got your
dad's got to see it I mean unless you
got a weird I know some people got that
weird relationship where their parents
left do you think it's because of the
dependability because if a woman is
living with her parents she's more
dependable
and that transfers to moving in with a
man and depending on him and submitting
to him that's that you know that's the
big difference like before the 20s
before that was like when women first
started to move out and have a period
between living with their parents and
living with their husband and that's
when you see like the birth rate start
to drop and marriage rates start to drop
was actually in their 20s the 60s like
accelerated it but it actually started
in the 20s and so you know it's kind of
I would say the evidence is clear that
like careers
uh me started kind of started the
downfall of like women like the family
unit to be honest I mean yeah 100
because obviously the woman's out of the
house more so she can't be in two places
at the same time of course and she can't
but no because you can have a family
when you have a business of course you
can it doesn't it's not
good what's the point bro but there's so
many women out there with that have
businesses
why don't you want to give like 100 of
them
the person that I am I know I could do
both I don't care what anyone says
it's not really like who's watching the
kids but you don't know when you're at
work who's watching the kids so I mean
when they're old enough they'll be in
school obviously when they're younger
they'll be in Nursery when they're a
baby I will be there all the time it's
not until that they're uh but business
is Cutthroat
if you don't if you're not so you you
can't just take five years off and then
come back this it is cut yeah I know of
course I because obviously every day
there's new things coming in so you have
to stay updated of course right but the
power of having this at my fingertip
well I could also be catering for my
child it's done I know people in real
estate that will be at home with their
kids but they're still doing business
calls yeah and I think that's the
problem to be honest I think that like I
think that's the way you look at it but
I I think we look at the outcomes what
has that done for society has it made it
better or worse like the family unit
stronger or weaker It's Made It weaker I
mean my parents like that's why kids are
so messed up now like you you have a mom
that's paying attention to her business
she's not paying attention to you so you
live in the same household but you
barely know her because she's spending
all the time I don't agree and you're on
your tablet and watching TV all day like
why do you think all these kids come out
with all this like God I'm so tired of
hearing these women's like trauma like
God my Trauma from my child is just yeah
and it's just it's just like it doesn't
lead to good outcomes yeah but I think
it's a balance though I think if if you
can balance having a business as having
a kid 100
child like I've already said that I
think having a family is more important
than my career because I need that I
need that I don't need a career I want
one because I know what I can offer and
what I want to get out of the world but
I need that family because without
having a husband and kids you have to
have it I won't have any family because
I've got family in Australia I've got
family in Scotland I only have I haven't
got any siblings so I won't have
brothers and sisters growing up do you
know what I mean that's very respectable
the fact that you want the kids with a
loving family that's good that's
respectable you know what I'm saying so
and you'd rather choose a family over a
job over a business if I had to make a
choice yes I would choose a family okay
but would you would you let me tell you
something
um would you prefer a rich guy that you
get married to not even rich like just
wealthy you know that can look after you
I can look after your kids yeah or would
you prefer to get married to the same
rich guy have the kids but I still want
no business for no reason well it
wouldn't be for no reason it would be
for no reason because you're already set
for yourself for life why do you need to
worry that's not me in my hand being set
for life relying on someone else because
he can walk and leave them you can walk
and leave him yeah
that's scarcity in life but this is
where yeah this is the propaganda that
they're always saying that you can't
rely on man you always need a backup
plan no you don't that is like it is
okay to need a man to know that you
can't live without him yeah then they
they teach you like I don't know why
they have this like fear-mongering in
women and they literally like it's it's
propaganda sorry go ahead no it's gonna
say I mean I I haven't once said that I
don't need a man because in fact I have
a family I need a man obviously
um but I just think women are so cute
capable of doing things for themselves
now that it's not that we don't need a
man but we don't need to rely on a man I
think that's them that I think it's I
think I love how modern women are I love
how Independent Women are I love how
powerful women are nowadays and I think
it's so I think you should encourage
women to want to do well for themselves
I just think it's so inspiring when you
see women doing what like the
Kardashians they have a family they take
no family and look at the outcomes like
genuinely is it good North is twerking
on Tick Tock I mean I don't agree with
that right I don't know and now they're
like kids and they're already exploiting
yeah and look at it look at what
happened like when he picked the modern
woman and you know I'll give Kim her
credit she's super successful yeah but
look at look at what it's done to their
family yeah she she divorced a
billionaire like the top what one
percent of men she divorced him and like
how how selfish is that for the kids and
that that's the problem is when we tell
women like our feelings come first like
that we translate that until we're
children where we won't stick anything
out for the sake of the kids
I heard that but also say if my I mean
my parents have been married for like 42
years I got married when they were 21.
wow yeah that's amazing yeah I mean for
that it's very rare to still have
parents that are still together as well
they like each other they they love each
other yeah they obviously they had their
moments where they're bickering but they
you can see the love and your mom stayed
right yeah yeah and that's that's they
don't make women like that anymore yeah
but if but from my perspective if I knew
my mum was unhappy I wouldn't want her
to stay you don't think in 42 years she
was ever unhappy oh I mean I know I know
that there's difficult times in marriage
of course but again
yeah so so you would say there were
times when she was unhappy and maybe not
as a younger kid I wouldn't have noticed
but now if if I saw that my mum was
unhappy I would want her to leave and it
was it but it was better that oh my God
wouldn't you say it was better that she
stayed because there were times that
come on in 42 years we both know that at
some point she was unhappy yeah there's
no way you go through 42 years in like
the person it's a choice right right
there's times I love I love my my
parents my siblings there are times when
I hate them yeah but you love them right
and so it's like this whole like we
don't talk about Duty responsibility uh
Legacy that we ruin all that when we
focus on our happiness it's not but like
marriage is supposed to be selfless it's
supposed to be about their happiness not
ours yeah bro I would like to add on to
that because my grandmother was
a traditional woman in a sense where she
stayed at home her husband worked our
grandfather
and she stayed home and cooked and
that's what she did my grandma was the
same she was together with him for 20 30
years to the day she died of cancer
right all right do you I was there I I
seen the unhappiness I haven't seen the
trials and tribulations for my
grandmother and my grandfather
I know she wasn't happy all the time but
regardless of whether she was happy or
not she stuck to her Duty he went to
work busted his ass came home and there
was a cooked meal and she cooked for me
and all my brothers and my grandfather
and everything she stuck to duty
regardless of her happiness because she
was traditional in the sense that you
know what's important is that I have a
meal that's going to protect and provide
for me and it's going to give me that
security and he's always going to be
there and what I have to provide as a
woman is I'm gonna give you a quick meal
I'm gonna give you that loyalty I'm
gonna give you that sexual exclusivity
and I'm gonna be here
and I think that women would get caught
up in this whole happiness thing where
it's like I got to be happy all the time
and by all means like happiness is truly
important but it's not the top priority
when you enter that marriage it's like
all right so what happens when you're 12
years in and you get unhappy and you're
just not happy for like a month two
months six months what you're just gonna
leave when you got a kid at home that's
dependent on you and the family that's
dependent on you you gotta stick it out
I'm talking about my grandfather was
there today my grandmother died through
cancer
were they necessarily happy at that end
no but it was Duty and I think that we
prioritize happiness and independency
over you know this this Duty and
marriage and it's really not about that
because
you know you do need a man you do need a
man like what's wrong with needing a man
like a man needs to feel needed like if
you're in a relationship with a woman
that you feel like she just doesn't need
you like why am I with you like if you
don't need me what am I with you for you
need to feel needed as a man in some
regard I'm not saying like every little
aspect of your life as a man you don't
got to be like I'm just saying just in
general like she's someone you look to
she he looks to you for guidance she
looks to for support when I'm confused
when you're confused and frustrated and
emotional and you're stressed out you go
to him of course yeah because he's your
best friend and he's more than that he
he's your everything yeah I think we
shouldn't be best friends with the men
yeah I want my husband not to be my best
friend I hope we have nothing in common
apparently I think it's something yeah
yeah I know I hope we have nothing and
why do you say that Pearl why do you say
that because
um I think when women and men are the
same like I think we we start to we
start to compete with the men and we
like you know I I just think that it's
better if we're super different and have
nothing in common and we're not best
friends because you can go off and do
your own things and then my best friends
I want to talk about the card I mean I'm
not a big Kardashian but it's just an
example right I want to talk about
stupid girl [__] with yeah I don't want
to talk about stupid girl [__] my
husband I don't want to do that to y'all
and him I wouldn't want to hear it and I
don't want my husband to talk to me the
same way he talks to a man I need it
softer than that you know what I know I
know it's the
be a bit disagreeable but in real life
I'm actually quite agreeable I don't
need the you ever hear I used to work at
a plumbing tech company right I used to
sell like
[__] to plumbers
and I want to do like a presentation at
one of them and it's like a super male
dominated environment I could not
believe the way that guy the guys were
talking to each other they were so mean
they were like roasting the [__] out of
each other like like you know they say
locker room taught you don't want to
hear it men like change the way they
talk a little bit when we're they're
around us like usually I was like if
this is how guys talk to each other I
don't want nothing keep keep talking to
me like you talk to a girl guys I don't
think I was talking about this Romeo
like guys will especially if you're a
good looking guy and a group of boys one
thing they'll do is if you have any sort
of flaw whether it's physical they're
going to point out that flow because
they have to have someone what up on you
if you're a good looking dude and you
get girls that have to be hard you're
overweight or this or that like your
friends you're friends with women you
would never be like oh yo Courtney I'm
not saying you're overweight I'm just
saying like you've never been like
Courtney you're overweight like come on
get your [__] you never say that but if
if he was overweight and he might do it
I'm like man you fat ass I'm saying like
that's the way women aren't like that
with each other you don't have that
brutal honesty and it's just play this
is my dude like I'm secretly I'm just
trying to motivate him to be better in
that way yeah I'm like yo yo yo you fat
as [__] yo yo go to the gym come to the
gym with me you know what I'm saying say
I say shut the [__] up let's go to my
face
you just talk differently yeah it's
direct it's direct but I think it's like
this whole programming of like the way
relationships should be like we program
us to say it's a partnership it's not a
partnership he's better than you and you
should probably listen to him but it's
even her she's looking at me like I'm
crazy saying this yes okay it's probably
the first time you've heard that but
it's like I don't think relationships
work when it's a partnership I don't
think relationships work when they're
your best friends I don't think that's
ideal I think you want a man that's
better than you and you can get guidance
from and I I think it's easier when you
defer to their Authority
um I do I do hear what you're saying and
I don't disagree with what you're saying
at all but
but you do a little bit yeah a little
bit I do a little bit it's just you
could say it it's just in the sense
this relax yeah I think it is good when
you're in a relationship though and
you're like complete opposite to the
other person but then it's good if you
are quite similar but then you just have
your time to yourself
when you need to you just need that
break but if you're opposite from what
your person wants how does that make any
how's that going to work because
Opposites Attract masculine yeah but
does it last yeah opposite no does it
work no actually I think masculine and
femininity is like opposite cool so
that's probably the only opposite that
would work though but she's talking
about this in general interest and and
morals and principles and things like
that I think that like your morals and
your values should be the same I agree
with you but yeah
do I want to go fishing with a guy with
your boys they don't want us there on
their boys trips anyway like they're
that's Hobbies promote that's more like
fun and hobby yeah
career completely different I don't but
if I'm talking about like what I want
out of life and what I see in the future
if she wants to be in the club all the
time and I and I oh yeah you know what
I'm saying that one it's not going to
work you can't be complete opposite we
have to be on some form of mutual
understanding Mutual ground yeah yeah
otherwise it's not gonna work and that's
the problem with most relationships you
guys have nothing in common I think it
comes down to mindset 100 having a
having a similar mindset to someone is
probably what you want to be honest
because if someone's got a higher
vibrational mindset than you you're
gonna you'll be drawn to it yeah you'll
probably achieve different things but if
you're a lower vibrational you'll you'll
just get bored of that person because
you'll be like I actually can't get
through to you you're not making sense
of what I'm saying because they're not
there do not mean they're not on that
level with you yeah no the comprehension
is about the person I don't think
anybody is above anyone which is why I
disagree with the whole um your man
should be better than you I agree with
the sense that you should learn from
your man vice versa with with
you why why would a man want to be with
a woman that he can't learn anything
from do you know what I mean I don't
think men want to learn anything from us
yeah
I'll tell them a fun fact from time to
time but you know like I don't know I
want to knock you feel important and
empowered as a man when you're leading
if you're leading if you're teaching me
that means you're in some form leading
me now I'm not saying that there are
situations where I'm dedicated to a girl
and she can teach me things I value you
guys don't like it
yeah because it makes them feel like
feeling bad
we're not actually I'm an intelligent
woman I think I think women shouldn't
play them a little bit and let them feel
like a guy you know you're not a bus you
know the best way to talk to women is
cute
yeah
cute if she likes him of course that's
what I'm talking about fear is one of
the sex that's cute creepy and
attractive
there's a limit to it though if it was
all the time then it'd be like nah like
I'm not playing with that I'm taking the
pissed around me yeah it's just like the
time they're only doing it to get what
they wanted yeah because they want to be
more empowered when it should just be
people let's say you love him yeah and
then he loves you he's like all my baby
come here let me give you a hug let me
squeeze your cheeks you're a little kid
yeah that is lovely to have yeah
then speak about serious subjects but
then men don't like that though say if I
did that to my man like oh it's all
right darling don't worry some men don't
say don't love and they can't lay on
your chest I've had that before with a
guy away you just can't even land my
chest because it belittles him which I
think is quite a sad thing yeah like
feel you should feel comfortable around
a woman and make them feel numb I think
I think it's the situation that made him
feel belittled like if you guys are just
hopping in the bed and cuddling and he's
laying on your chest then that's just
empowering and it's beautiful it's love
between men and a woman but if it's you
doing it no but if it's you doing it
because he's struggling or he's having
an issue it's just normal lie like I
said if it's normal like if you guys
just come home obey how you doing Kiss
And you lay in the bed and he's Landing
chips that's that's empowering but if he
comes home and he's expressing his
emotions and [__] like that you're like
babe come here nah that's something he
should do to you when you come home and
say I had a stressful day this girl was
talking [__] about me blah blah blah
blah and you lay in bed and I bet I got
you it's completely different it I think
it was the situation for it
um to be honest maybe I don't know
yeah I'm gonna Read Super chats really
quick
um and then we're probably gonna close
out the show it's crazy how much calmer
it got when that guy left right yeah
yeah she's like oh my gosh
um okay Serge you need to rely on a man
because there isn't enough time in the
day to take care of both your children
and your career properly that's why the
family unit exists because you need both
interracial relationships grown men have
to acquire maintain status wealth and
power in order to have a chance to
obtain sex from a woman while a woman
can merely ask a man without any
possessions for sex and which her level
UPS from zero to a hundred percent zero
Fallout don't blame social media it is
exposing women let them talk and they
will snitch what older men said about
women is now being proven Johnny look at
her not listening this is the problem Mr
witch Gene if you go to a club you can
get into just you can get in just for
looking good a man has to pay for him
and if he makes you pay for himself he
gets looked down on um
Caleb um can you cook seven plus good
meals a week are you low damage low
stress respectful or promiscuous can't
cook can't clean can't act right and are
selfish what are you just babies that's
low value
um Jessica Garcia if you say I don't
need a man you aren't with the right man
because the right man will make your
life so much easier and fulfill the
voids no amount of Independence or
confidence can Dragon stallion if you
want um a parachuting and they said
there's a 36 probability of the shoot
not opening would you jump women with 10
or more sexual partners has a 36
probability of divorce within five years
87 probability by year 10. of Johnny
yella manifests those skills LOL Tim
norath bro do you understand bro do you
understand bro bro do you understand so
distasteful of words bird brain bro do
you understand Gus black clothes doesn't
live in reality is too feminine lies to
women Leila is by definition of 304 the
man to the left is the worst kind of man
to date he got kicked out because he
acted like an emotional woman I'm Clint
a man civilized by a good woman is a
tale as old as time but if if said woman
gives a guy everything he wants what he
wants he gives no him no incentive to to
change himself Jack quis respect the man
walking out he did not walk out he got
kicked out Pearl has some has been on
some other stuff lately rude uh show has
gone from respectable conversation to
pandering he gets kicked out
um but the drunk who is cutting off
everyone including Pearl gets free reign
Bretta once an addict always an addict
uh Clint I'm getting oh I'm getting
Vibes in the back I'm gonna refresh it
really quick and see if there's any new
ones
um
okay no there isn't
um okay well I think I'm gonna close out
the show it's like 1am so
[Music]
um do you guys have any final thoughts
you want to add you can plug in your
social medias now um thank you guys for
coming thank you for having me this was
a very good show after the corner man
left
um yeah just thank you for having us and
I think um you've really inspired me
even more to start my own podcast
because I want to stop my own podcast so
just seeing how you do it has really
inspired me and motivated me to continue
with mine
um but at the gram guys it's Ashton
Maria
good I am thankful to be on this podcast
and I'm happy that we spoke about
everything and agreed to disagree even
though I just disagree with majority of
this stuff that was funny about but
everyone has different perspectives and
mindsets and
everyone's different you know so yeah
um my Ig is Courtney Brown why why
something like that I just want to say
thank you for the opportunity and
letting us come on this show
and it's made me realize a lot more
about actually respecting myself and who
I am as a woman and I want to change and
I will push yourself
but it's been a great experience it's on
camera though so much it's on camera
hi guys
um but yeah my Instagram's miss Layla
Linda make sure you give me a follow and
yeah thank you for watching
laugh
thank you guys for watching
anyway I'm the owner of the biggest
group in the industry only found
industry hoes in cash make sure you tell
me to join it we've got 350 members I
know making a killing since they join my
Instagram is broken it's K1 and my
Twitter is Jose cash I'll see you there
Maji here 350 only fans girls
oh you manage though I'm gonna six only
fun skills and I have a group of guys
uh oh I see I was like wow that is huge
that's impossible that's impossible okay
go ahead yeah I just want to say I
appreciate the opportunity even though
if we butt a heads a few times and we
disagreed on points I think the most
beautiful thing to realize is that we
had a conversation
and we came to you know just listening
to each other I think that's the most
important thing it doesn't matter if we
agree we can disagree and butt heads and
move forward uh you can follow me at IG
at Giovanni underscore ydp
um yeah give me a follow
[Laughter]
um okay guys a couple announcements
before we end the show you already know
two clips channels just pearly clips and
pearl daily
cheers all right fourth tier is a
one-on-one call with me once a month I
really recommend this if you're trying
to start a podcast
um I can give you a lot of insights and
save you a lot of time
um also guys follow my Instagram just
pearly things one and subscribe to wife
school um there's a new episode coming
out soon and also tune in this week we
are releasing all of the dating show
content so the red pill Bachelor does
air this week um we have an episode
coming out with MTR we filmed one with
sneako and we have a bunch oh and
Melanie King also did an episode so
we're releasing all footage so um watch
out for that this week
um subscribe to our three talents um
King Richie's Auntie Jenny and Amir
Amiri is almost um it's the fresh prince
of like Zamunda something like that I
don't know what is uh but he's at 769
subscribers so we really want to get
them monetized so go subscribe to his
channel we really want to get him to a
thousand if you guys can make sure
that's in the chat and also we're going
to do a meet up we're going to try to do
a meet up before we leave
um so sign up for a Google form we're
also going to do some meetups in the U.S
like the video on your way out subscribe
to the channel and we'll talk to you
next time
[Applause]
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
yo what's going on people King rich is
back again with another podcast good
evening and hi and welcome to Auntie
Jenny's video channel to Jenny's podcast
it's your boy The Fresh Prince of
someone
but I've been coffee free for four
months okay I gotta say that how could
everyone have someone out there for them
when there's more women than men now I'm
not saying you have to be submissive to
every old waste man walking around I'm
just saying that it would be femininity
would be in your nature breaking it is
to find somebody you're compatible with
that you'd like not just of your same
generation and that likes the same
things that you do going out having fun
okay okay then then get out then get out
faster then get out I'm not here to get
canceled today most men want a woman
that has some degree of femininity where
they feel like they're taking care of
taking care of I'm lady night I'm
submissive and you'll be surprised
because I will say what I want to say
now and I'll say what I want to say with
my mind but my demeanor doesn't change
and I'm going to look down on him
because at the end of the day whoever
you're with is a reflection of you what
has happened to society that has made
the normal man a waste man I would feel
so bad asking a guy to buy like a three
thousand dollar bag
now he's
foreign